bonjour à tous ravi de vous retrouver
sur publ Sénat pour suivre dans un
instant les débats des sénateurs autour
d'une proposition de loi socialiste
débattu en procédure accélérée déjà
adoptée à laassemblée nationale une
proposition de loi socialiste portant
sur l'indépendance le pluralisme et la
liberté des médias c'est un texte qui
étant la liberté éditoriale à toutes les
rédactions avec la mise en place de
Comité de déontologie mais aussi il a
signé ature de charte de déontologie
dans toutes les rédactions mais c'est
aussi un texte qui renforce la
protection des sources une nécessité
encore démontré par l'actualité
l'affaire des Panama papers c'est ce qu'
a pu dire hier après-midi dans
l'hémicycle la ministre de la Culture
Audrey Azou qui selon elle voit dans
cette affaire la pertinence de cette
proposition de loi la liberté des médias
et bien c'est la garante d'une
démocratie moderne notez également ce
qu'a pu dire Catherine main de dit
sénatrice UD UC présidente de la
commission de la culture et bien pour
elle il faut lutter contre la place que
peuvent prendre les annonceur par
rapport à la liberté des journalistes
elle a également pris le cas de la
déprogrammation d'un reportage sur le
Crédit Mutuel sur Canal plus tout de
suite donc retour au débat dans
l'hémicycle madame la
présidente madame la Présidente
rapporteur de la commission de la
culture de l'éducation et de la
communication monsieur le rapporteur de
la commission des lois mesdames et
messieurs les
sénateurs après nos échanges fructueux
sur le projet de loi relatif à la
liberté de création à l'architecture et
au patrimoine en février je suis
heureuse d'être à nouveau avec vous au
Sénat pour travailler à cette
proposition de loi en faveur de la
liberté et l'indépendance des médias
permettez-moi de saisir cette
occasion pour nous féliciter globalement
du large succès des opérations de de
passage de la télévision à la haute
définition hier succès rendu possible
par l'excellent travail législatif
coproduit à l'Assemblée nationale par
Patrick Bloche et par le Sénat notamment
votre rapporteur Catherine main de sa
que je veux remercier et aussi saluer le
travail intense qui a été mené en terme
de mise en œuvre par le Conseil
supérieur de l'audiovisuel et par
l'Agence nationale des
fréquences s'agissant de la proposition
de loi que vous examinez
aujourd'hui la liber l'indépendance et
le pluralisme des médias sont les
objectifs vers lesquels nous devons nous
ne devons cesser de tendre et c'est au
législateur qu'il incombe de protéger
ses valeurs nous y sommes tous ici
attachés je le sais l'actualité de ces
derniers jours nous donne une éclatante
illustration du service que les médias
peuvent rendre à la société ils peuvent
contribuer de façon majeure par leur
capacité d'investigation et par leur
poids dans le débat public au bon
fonctionnement de notre
démocratie je ne doute pas que le projet
de loi sur l'indépendance des médias
dont je veux sincèrement remercier ses
auteurs et ses rapporteurs avec qui mon
ministère a pu mener un travail je crois
fécond contribua contribuera à garantir
leur indépendance et à protéger cette
liberté lorsque cette proposition de loi
est passée à l'Assemblée j'ai tenu à ce
que plusieurs amendements soient adoptés
le premier restreint la mise en place
des comités d'indépendance de l'article
7 aux radio généraliste à vocation
nationale contenu du nombre de radios
loc
trop important pour envisager leur
généralisation j'ai également fait
adopter un nouvel article 9 bis qui tend
à interdire la vente d'une chaîne de
télévision dans un délai de 5 ans
suivant la délivrance de l'autorisation
par le
CSA cette disposition vise à protéger le
domaine public artien du jeu
spéculatif enfin j'ai présenté à
l'assemblée un amendement fondamental il
me semble relatif au renforcement de la
protection du secret des sources des
journalistes et des collaborateurs de
rédaction je reviendrai plus loin in sur
cette mesure forte en faveur elle aussi
de la liberté de la presse et qui se
s'intégrait donc parfaitement dans cette
proposition de
loi mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
à votre tour vous êtes saisi de cette
proposition sous votre autorité
bienveillante madame la Présidente chère
Catherine main de sa la commission de la
culture de l'éducation et de la
communication au Sénat a travaillé à
imprimer sa marque au texte j'ai suivi
avec beaucoup d'intérêt vos débats en
commission et je me réjouis des points
d'accord que vos travaux ont permis nous
les évoquerons en détail dans le cours
de nos échanges je voudrais d'abord
souligner auprès de vous deux points qui
correspondent à autant de lignes de
force de ce texte premièrement la
protection de la liberté éditoriale des
journalistes l'article 1er permet
d'étendre à tous les journalistes quels
que soient les médias dans lesquels ils
travaillent une protection qui depuis
son introduction en 2009 dans la loi de
1986 sur l'audiovisuel protégeit les
journalistes de l'audiovisuel public
elle était en vigueur bien
antérieurement à cela mais dans le droit
conventionnel votre proposition de
rédaction de l'article 1er entend
concilier la garantie des droits des
journalistes avec l'obligation faite aux
entreprises de presse de se doter d'une
charte de déontologie une charte
respectueuse de la ligne éditoriale
définie par la direction de chaque titre
mais qui aura d'autant plus de force
qu'elle aura été élaborée par l'équipe
dirigeante et les journalistes cette
rédaction va être débattue peut-être
enrichie pour tenir compte aussi des
équilibres trouvés à l'Assemblée
nationale la charte de déontologie je le
soulligne peut également contribuer à
renforcer c'est la confiance des
lecteurs des téléspectateurs et des
auditeurs envers les organismes de
presse deuxème point la création de
comités relatifs à l'honnêteté
l'indépendance et le pluralisme de
l'information et des programmes comité
que j'appellerai par souci de simplicité
les comité indépendance sans porter
atteinte à la liberté éditoriale des
éditeurs de télévision et de radio non
plus à la responsabilité du directeur de
publication ces comités doivent
permettre de traiter d'une manière
transparente et concertée toute menace
sur l'indépendance d'un média qui serait
porté à sa
connaissance vos travaux ont restreint
les modalités de cisine que vous avez
jugé trop ouvertes de ces
comités ce comité permettra à certaines
personnes désormais mieux plus définies
de le consulter je pense ici au
médiateur là où ils existent afin de
garantir à nos concitoyens la défense de
l'intérêt général par ailleurs votre
proposition permet de préciser le rôle
du CSA et les règles de mise en place
des comités d'indépendance pour que
chacun soit bien dans son rôle et qu'il
n'y ait pas de
confusion mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs je voudrais enfin évoquer
l'amélioration des garanties àorté au
secret des sources des journalistes
c'est un enjeu démocratique
majeur vous connaissez ma détermination
est-ce que cette loi et que ce point
particulier soit adopté conformément à
un engagement que le Président de la
République à leur candidat euh avait
pris il nous appartient tous ensemble de
trouver le point d'équilibre le plus
juste entre la sécurité que nous devons
garantir aux journalistes dans leur
travail d'investigation indispensable à
la démocratie et la possibilité encadré
d'enquêter dans des cas précis où cela
s'avère nécessaire pour la sécurité de
nos concitoyens en adoptant l'amendement
gouvernemental que j'ai l'honneur de
porter que j'ai eu l'honneur de porter
l'assemblée national a défini je crois
les contours d'un bon équilibre les
insuffisances de la législation
existante ont été corrigées pour
permettre à la presse d'investigation de
faire son travail sans risque de mettre
ses sources en
difficulté l'enquête menée par les plus
grandes rédaction mondiale sur l'évasion
fiscale au Panama les Panama papers
illustre s'il en était besoin la
pertinence l'actualité la nécessité de
cette loi permettez-moi de rappeler
quelques-unes des avancées majeures du
texte l'obligation faite aux enquêteurs
d'obtenir l'autorisation préalable du
juge de la liberté et de la détention
avant toute action pouvant porter
atteinte au secret des sources ce
contrôle s'effectué à postériori dans la
loi de 2010 il sera désormais à priori
citons également l'extens de la
protection du secret des sources à tous
les collaborateurs de la rédaction au
directeurs de publication bref à toute
la chaîne de recherche de l'information
là où la loi de 2010 visait uniquement
le journaliste je veux citer encore
l'interdiction de condamner un
journaliste pour le délit de recelle
d'une violation du secret de l'enquête
ou de l'instruction d'une violation du
secret professionnel ou d'une atteinte à
la vie
privée vous avez souhaité déléguer le
travail parlementaire sur cette partie
du texte à la commission des Lois du
Sénat et cette mission a fait le choix
de ne pas retenir la plus grande partie
de ses avancées et de revenir aux
principales dispositions de la loi de
2010 je le regrette et je souhaite que
les travaux que nous aurons en séance
publique permettent de revenir à des
dispositions que je crois bonnes pour
notre
démocratie j'espère sur ce point avoir
votre soutien voilà chère Catherine main
de sa cher David Assouline mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs les grandes
lignes de ce que je voulais réaffirmer
devant vous au sujet de cette loi que je
vous proposerai d'adopter garantir la
indépendance des médias protéger leur
sources c'est construire une démocratie
moderne solide sur ses bases et capable
d'affronter le monde d'aujourd'hui je
vous
remerci merci Madame la
Ministre la parole est à Madame
Catherine main de sailli rapporteur de
la commission de la culture de
l'éducation et de la communion et de la
communication pardon je vous en prie
chère
Catherine madame la la présidente madame
la ministre mes très chers collègues
renforcer la liberté l'indépendance et
le pluralisme des médias on ne peut bien
sûr que souscrire aux objectifs de la
proposition de loi qui nous vient de
l'assemblée corelaire de la liberté
d'expression la liberté d'information
est un des fondamentaux de toute
démocratie nous le mesurons chaque jour
que ce soit sur notre sol où certains
ont voulu l'avoir abattu ou pas très
loin de chez nous en Europe même je
pense aujourd'hui à la régression des
libertés des médias en polonne en
Hongrie en Croatie et hélas les exemples
sont nombreux de par le monde à cet
égard je tiens à saluer le travail
remarquable de défense des journalistes
de reporter sans frontières en France la
situation semble a priori satisfaisante
l'accès à l'information n'a jamais été
aussi aisé la pluralité des supports
d'information est foisonnante la
diversité des médias n'a jamais été
aussi importante même si la presse
écrite souffre pour des raisons que nous
connaissons tous les journaux d'opinion
fort heureusement existe toujours du
quotidien local à la chaîne
d'information étrangère les sources
d'information sont multiples et
accessibles le développement d'une
presse gratuite depuis une quinzaine
d'années la révolution numérique et
l'apparition des réseaux sociaux
nouveaux pourvoyeurs d'information eux
ont eux aussi changer jusqu'aux usages
de nos concitoyens une étude de
Médiamétrie paru la semaine dernière a
particulièrement attiré mon attention
elle montre que si les Français
s'informment toujours massivement via
les médias traditionnels 80 % par par la
télévision 52 % par les chaînes
d'information en continu 49 % par les
radios et 49 % par la presse ils sont
aussi de plus en plus nombreux à
s'informer via les médias numériques
portail et page d'actualité pure players
et réseaux sociaux ils étaient 34 % en
2013 ils sont 38 % cette année en 2016
et cette progression bien entendu n'est
pas prête d'être enrayée outre la remise
en cause du modèle économique des médias
traditionnel que cela pose c'est un
véritable défi démocratique que nous
sommes confrontés en effet la
multiplicité des informations diffusé
sur Internet pose plus encore que par le
passé les questions de la vérification
des sources de la qualité du recoupement
des faits exposés et du caractère
professionnel des personnes qui
diffusent ces informations dans ce
foisonnement cette pléor de canaux
d'information sousiste toujours un
soupçon insidieux l'information qui nous
est délivrée est-elle véritablement un
indépendante hier ce soupçon visait le
monde politique aujourd'hui il s'est
tourné vers le monde économique en effet
devant l'affaiblissement structurel des
acteurs historiques et le besoin
grandissant de capitaux pour assurer une
modernisation devenu
indispensable le recours à de puissants
investisseurs extérieurs au monde des
médias s'est progressivement imposé
rachat des éch par LVMH prise de
contrôle du monde par mieur Nil berger
pigas au capital de vivindi de
l'Industrielle Vincent Boloré rachat de
49 % de Next TV next radio TV par Altis
ces prises de participation dans des
médias majeurs se sont accompagné
d'autres rachats dans la perspective de
constituer des groupes de taille
critique qui ont en quelques années
considérablement redessiné l'univers des
médias en France libération et L'Express
ont rejoint Altis le Nouvel Observateur
a été repris par le monde daily motion a
été racheté par
vivindi l'émergence de ces nouveaux
groupes de médias géré comme de
véritables sociétés industriel a eu des
incidences sur l'exercice de leur métier
par les journalistes qui d'une part ont
été amenés à revoir leur méthodes de
travail pour intervenir sur l'ensemble
des supports et d'autre part ont souvent
dû accepter de s'inscrire dans une
logique de groupe plus ou moins
publicitaire dès lors se pose
légitimement la question de l'influence
des annonceurs sur la ligne éditoriale
de ces médias pourtant les cas
d'interférence sont connus et à juste
titre dénoncé même s'il demeur rare en
2009 le site Rue 89 se faisait l'écho de
la suppression dans le numéro du 29
janvier du journal Direct Matin d'un
article qui expliquait en détail comment
la RATP exploite les données du passe
Navigo à des fins commerciales en 2011
MDI part dénoncer un autre cas de
censure concernant la publication
géohistoire qui avait supprimé plusieurs
pages consacrées à la collaboration des
entreprises françaises dans un dossier
consacré à l'occupation plus récemment
c'est la nouvelle direction de Canal
Plus qui a été montré du doigt à
l'occasion d'intervention sur la
programmation de son magazine special
investigation un reportage portant sur
le Crédit Mutuel ayant fait l'objet
d'une déprogrammation et des sujets
d'enquête ayant été refusés par la
direction éditoriale le Conseil
supérieur de l'audiovisuel c'est
légitime ement saisi de l'affaire en
septembre
2015 et a obtenu des évolutions avec la
création d'un comité de déontologie pour
iTélé Canal Plus et la rédaction d'une
charte donc des engagements afin de
renforcer les garanties relatives à
l'indépendance éditoriale dans le cas
d'espèces la régulation expost exercée
par le CSA semble donc avoir fonctionné
et rien ne semblait par conséquent
justifié a priori de de recourir à une
initiative législative qui plus est dans
l'urgence auditionné par notre
commission le 23 mars dernier Olivier
schramec le président du CSA a
d'ailleurs rappelé que le Conseil
n'avait jamais demandé de modification
législativ c'est dans ce contexte qu'en
février 2016 deux propositions de loi
ont néanmoins été successivement
déposées sur le bureau des deux
assemblée et je donne acte à notre
collègue David Assouline comme je l'ai
dit en commission de l'antériorité de sa
réflexion puisqu'il est l'auteur d'une
première proposition de loi sur
l'indépendance des rédactions déposé en
2011 je tiens tout d'abord à rappeler
malgré tout les mauvaises conditions
dans lesquelles nous avons dû examiner
ces textes absence d'études d'impact et
de concertation préalable tous ou
presque l'ont déploré urgence déclaré
sur le texte examen tout juste 4
semaines après l'adoption à l'Assemblée
nationale que nous avons pourtant réussi
à mettre à profit pour entendre de
grands de nombreux acteurs des médias
français examen qui enfin sera
vraisemblaement tronqué au cours de cet
après-midi et voyer au mieux en fin de
session si je regrette que les textes
que nous examinons proposent de
remplacer un système souple de
régulation interne au cœur des
entreprises et externes par le CSA qui
devient non plus un régulateur mais un
censeur du monde des médias j'ai voulu
m'inscrire dans une démarche
constructive j'ai aussi proposé que
notre commission s'attellele à
distinguer l'urgence de l'important et
demeurer concrète tout d'abord
réaffirmer le bien fondé des principes
de transparence honnêteté indépendance
pluralisme de l'information et des
programmes ainsi nous crivons à ce que
le droit d'opposition des journalistes
soit inscrit dans la loi que les
entreprises se dotent de chre et de
comités de
déontologie ce sont des sujets tout à
fait essentiels mais nous avons veillé à
ce que ces principes trouvent leur juste
traduction dans des dispositifs
pertinents et opérationnels qui n'entrav
pas le bon fonctionnement des
entreprises et qui prennent en compte ce
travail collectif qui est un journal
dans le respect de chacun avec une
chaîne de responsabilité clairement
établie nous avons tâché d'éviter toute
imiction injustifiée du législateur
pensant que les entreprises sont déjà
suffisamment encadré de normes ou de
contraintes pour ne pas en rajouter de
supplémentaires c'est pourquoi la
Commission de la culture a prévu que les
modalités d'élaboration de la Charte
puissent s'adapter à chaque entreprise
bien sûr en matière de déontologie il y
a un référentiel commun mais il y a
aussi une histoire et une culture propre
à chacun à limité le rôle du comité
d'entreprise en matière de contrôle de
la déontologie des journalistes préciser
que le CSA veille à l'honnêteté à
l'indépendance et au pluralisme de
l'information et des programmes sans
qu'il ne devienneent l'arbitre entre les
journalistes et leurs employeurs
supprimer enfin la possibilité de
saisine de ces comités par toutes
personne et ouvert un droit de saisine à
la Société des journalistes et je vous
proposerai aussi quelques autres
amélioration deux dernières choses avant
de cidder la parole à mon collègue Hu
Portelli qui exposera le point de vue de
la commission des lois sur la création
d'un régime de protection du secret
desessources qui est là une vraie utile
avancée
premièrement je suis vraiment favorable
à un travail approfondi sur la
déontologie celle-ci est en effet au
cœur de la crédibilité des médias cela
veut dire qu'elle doit s'inscrire dans
le cadre d'un dialogue permanent au sein
de l'entreprise le journal encore une
fois c'est un collectif n eu d'ailleurs
de cesse de nous le dire nos nombreux
interlocuteurs la déontologie ce sont
bien sûr les droits mais aussi les
responsabilités de la action et des
journalistes tel que l'a encore
récemment rappelé le président de
l'Observatoire de la déontologie de
l'information Patric
dans son dernier rapport annuel il
rappelait notamment les
dysfonctionnements qui ont eu lieu dans
le cadre du traitement de l'information
suite aux attentats du début de l'année
2015 deuxièmement l'enjeu pour les
médias traditionnel français selon moi
n'est pas l'adoption de telle ou telle
proposition de loi au Parlement français
fut-elle pleine de bon bonnes intentions
et proposant quelques avancées l'enjeu
et leur adaptation à un paysage de
l'information mes chers collègues en
complète recomposition avec l'entrée sur
le marché de l'information des grands
acteurs internationaux de l'Internet et
des réseaux sociaux là se trouve à terme
si nous n'y prenons pas garde la
véritable menace pour le pluralisme et
l'indépendance des médias français on se
souviendra de la manière dont le géant
Google a fait l'omô de quelques millions
d'euros aux éditeurs de presse pour
solldte de tout compte il y a quelques
années à leur réclamation sans aborter
de solutions au problèm structurels du
nouveau et juste partage de la valeur
ajoutée que génère la mutation numérique
je trouve donc que le débat engendré par
ces deux PPL même s'il était nécessaire
est quelque peu défasé au regard des
immenses défis mes chers collègues qui
sont devant nous je vous remercie de
votre attention merci
beaucoup Monsieur H Portelli rapporteur
pour avis de la commission des lois a la
parole madame la présidente madame la
ministre madame la Présidente de la
Commission des de la culture juste
quelques mots pour vous donner le point
de vue de la commission des lois sur un
article du texte de la proposition de
loi je rappelle que c'est pas un projet
de loi mais une proposition de loi et
qui concerne donc la protection du
secret des sources alors d'abord un
rappel ce secret des sours est bien
protégé il est bien protégé par une loi
en vigueur qui date de 2010 et cette loi
de 2010 a été élaborée pour intégrer
dans le droit français la jurisprudence
de la Cour européenne et droits de
l'homme et ça a été fait c'est le droit
qui est actuellement appliqué en France
par nos tribunaux et je connais assez
bien la jurisprudence de la Cour
européenne des droits de l'homme je n'ai
pas souvenir qu'il y ait eu beaucoup de
modifications de cette jurisprudence
depuis 2010 car les grands arrêts de la
Cour en la matière datent des années
1990 et 2000 alors pourquoi a-t-on voulu
modifier ce texte on a voulu le modifier
pour tenir compte d'autres points de vue
qui était notamment celui qui avait été
sollicité de la commission consultative
des droit de française et non pas de la
CEDH donc le droit français actuel est
parfaitement conforme au droit européen
en la matière alors qu'est-ce qu'a fait
la commission des lois et bien tout
simplement elle a vérifier si la
proposition de loi qui lui était soumise
dans l'article qui la concernit
c'est-à-dire la protection du secret des
sources était conforme premièrement au
droit du Conseil de l'Europe et
deuxièmement au droit français tel qu'il
s'applique à habituellement et tel que
les juges l'appliquent et elle a
remarqué un certain nombre de
différences qu'elle a voulu corriger et
elle a voulu les corriger pour revenir à
un droit plus conforme à un équilibre
hein et en cela je considère que le
travail qui a été accompli par la
commission des lois sur ce petit article
Inter est une avancée pour parler comme
Madame la Ministre et non pas un recul
car c'est un une avancée de l'État de
droit pourquoi parce que dans le droit
français et dans le droit européen il y
a un principe qui est celui de l'égalité
devant la loi c'estàdire que tous les
citoyens sont égaux devant la loi y
compris les journalistes y compris les
journalistes et il y a un deuxième
principe aussi c'est celui de la
protection du secret non pas simplement
des sources des journalistes mais aussi
du secret de l'instruction du secret de
la vie privée du secret de la défense
nationale et par les temps qui courent
ces secrets-là il compent autant que le
secret des sources alors la commission
des lois est intervenue pour veiller au
respect de tous ces secrets et à leur
harmonisation alors dans le mot secret
des sources il y a un mot qui est
important c'est le mot secret c'est le
mot secret qu'est-ce qu'un secret c'est
quelque chose qu'on divulgue pas trop y
compris les sources et le premier point
sur lequel la Commission des loi s'est
interrogé c'était de savoir qui
bénéficiait du secret des sources les
journalistes bon très bien alors qui est
journaliste qui est bénéficiaire du
secret des sources en tant que
journaliste et la commission des lois a
veillé à maintenir une définition claire
du journaliste parce que si tout le
monde est journaliste si tout le monde
bénéficie du secret des sources ce n'est
plus un secret ce n'est plus un secret
tout le monde peut le divulguer donc
première première chose maintenir une
définition qui est celle d'ailleurs de
la loi 1881 et Madame la Ministre de la
jurisprudence qui interprète cette loi
de 1881 et qui l'inprète de notre point
de vue de façon extrêmement libérale en
faveur du monde de la presse la deuxième
question sur laquelle nous sommes
interrogés c'est à propos de la façon
dont le l'amendement du Gouvernement qui
a été glissé en cours de débat à
l'Assemblée car c'est vrai que c'est une
proposition de loi mais c'est vrai que
l'article Inter et ce point de vue là
votre lapsus est tout à fait intéressant
est vrai c'est un c'est un amendement
qui est rédigé par le gouvernement cet
article inter c'est un article
gouvernemental sauf qu'il a été écrit un
peu vite madame la ministre il a été
écrit tellement vite qu'il y a des
erreurs de rédaction et que par exemple
entre ce que vous attribuez c'est pas
vous mais c'est vos collègues de du
ministère de la Justice en tout cas de
la direction des affaires pénales et des
grâces ce qu'ils attribu au code de
procédure pénale ils ont oublié de le
mettre dans le code pénal ou dans le
code de de la presse donc voilà on a
essayé de remettre tout cela un petit
peu à l'écire de faire en sorte que
quand on parle de prévention et de
répression on en parle partout que quand
on parle de crime et et de délit et bien
on en parle un petit peu partout
également et que tout ça soit écrit en
français juridique correct voilà le
travail qui a été fait par la commission
des lois et puis on a été je termine
là-dessus nous avons rétabli le délit de
recel du secret de l'instruction car
enfin respecter le secret de l'enquête
le secret de l'instruction c'est un
droit fondamental c'est un droit
essentiel et le supprimer ce serait pas
une avancé ce serait un recul grave de
l'État de droit je vous donne un exemple
madame le ministre vous avez peut-être
remarqué que l'an dernier la Cour de
cassation a condamné oui je vais
terminer là-dessus mais c'est important
madame a condamné un journaliste pour
avoir divulgué partout le portrait robot
d'un violeur en série alors que c'était
couvert par le secret de l'instruction
est-ce que vous croyez que c'est une
avancée cela alors méditez-le et nous en
parlerons au cours du débat merci chers
collègues Monsieur David
Assouline auteur de la proposition de
loi numéro 416 pour le groupe socialiste
et républicain
oui merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre madame la Présidente et Madame
la rapporteur mes chers collègues le
groupe socialiste et républicain a
choisi d'inscrire dans cette niche
parlementaire ces deux textes en
discussion commune et la commission de
la culture a
proposé de travailler sur la base du
texte qui nous vient de la Assemblée
nationale qui est déclarée en urgence
par le gouvernement et qui donc va
pouvoir suivre une
navette ce qui n'est pas le cas de
toutes les PPL que nous discutons au
Sénat tendant à aboutir à un texte qui
je l'espère sera promulgué et un texte
de la République bientôt donc nous
discutons là pas seulement pour poser
des grands principes ce qui est parfois
le cas des niches mais pour vraiment
faire la loi et c'est la perspective que
nous avons à court terme euh certains se
sont posés alors la question mais
pourquoi urgence et pourquoi privilégier
une
telle une telle loi dans notre agenda
parlementaire est-ce utile je veux
d'abord démontrer proclamer son
utilité probablement on ne pouvait pas
quand on l'a inscrit prévoir les
contingences qui forment l'actualité de
façon relativement massive depuis 48 he
l'indépendance de la presse c'est non
seulement un impératif de la démocratie
Victor Hugo disait que c'est à mettre
sur le même pied mais en même temps
comme quelque chose d'inséparable du
suffrage
universel comme liberté et gage d'une
démocratie vivante mais aussi dans le
monde puisque ce qui nous est démontré
depuis de jours c'est bien que quelque
chose qui est
important pour l'avenir du
monde pour ses équilibres économiques
pour l'idée qu'on peut se faire du
bien-être dans le monde d'une économie
saine et bien a bien été dévoilé par la
presse
international par le travail de
journalistes qui ont pu le faire alors
qu'on pourrait se dire que les États et
les instances internationales ont tous
les moyens de faire en sorte que
l'opinion se saisisse de ces sujets et
impose des pratiques plus
virtueuses vertueuses dans le domaine
des échanges financiers c'est la presse
qui l'a fait et on doit l'acter et je
remercie d'ailleurs le président de la
République et Monsieur sapin d'avoir
commenté cet événement
en commençant par remercier le travail
des journalistes qui ont permis cela qui
permettent d'informer de mobiliser
l'opinion et de donner la force à nos
gouvernants plus de
force quand il le voulent et puis aussi
un peu de pression et de contrainte pour
ceux qui ne le voulaient
pas de réguler mieux la finance
internationale et de lutter contre les
paradis fiscaux donc voilà une
démonstration concrète de l'utilité de
toujours remettre sur le chantier cette
question de l'indépendance alors le
principal argument de ceux qui
considèrent que ce n'était pas
d'actualité était de dire mais voyons
est-ce que cette liberté des médias où
cette indépendance est menacée dans
notre pays il n'y a jamais eu autant de
médias il n'y a jamais eu tant de
structure il n'y a jamais eu tempant
autant de
d'auditeurs et sur l'ensemble des
supports que ce soit les télés il y a
beaucoup de chaînes que ce soit avec le
net beaucoup de plateformes que ce soit
la press écrite pas mal de titres mais
ce que l'on peut constater justement
aujourd'hui c'est que dans
cette
explosion des titres sur tous les
supports il y a de moins en moins de
comment dire il y a plutôt de plus en
plus de
propriétaire unique qui possède
l'essentiel de cette pluralité et donc
cette offre massive ne correspond pas
forcément à un pluralisme d'expression
et d'opinion vous pouvez avoir des
chaînes qui ont des noms différents un
groupe derrière la même ligne éditoriale
voire même des mêmes articles mais on
change le titre et on donne l'illusion
de cette unité et donc il faut
s'attacher
à dans cet univers qui vient de bouger
qui bouge plutôt de plus en plus depuis
quelques années de façon accélérée parce
qu'il y a aussi les mutations
technologiques parce qu'il y a la
nécessité que je ne conteste pas dans la
concurrence internationale d'avoir des
grands groupes pour
résister parce que il y a aussi si nous
n'étions pas en capacité en France avec
nos groupes de fournir l'offre
médiatique et d'information on sait que
dans le monde sans frontières
d'aujourd'hui ce serait des grands
groupes étrangers qui viendrai donc le
problème n'est pas de contester cela
mais de faire attention parce que dans
notre pays il y a deux caractéristiques
qui potentiellement et des fois ça se
vérifie dans la pratique madame
rapporteur vous avez évoqué des cas mais
potentiellement son problème
il y a que quelques grands groupes de
médias audiovisuel qui possède quasi
l'ensemble et c'est pareil dans ce qui
était le fleuron de la diversité au
lendemain de la guerre la presse
quotidienne régionale qui la presse la
plus
lu aujourd'hui en presse écrite c'était
quoi et bien il y avait des titres par
courant d'opinion dans notre pays ça
pouvaitre si titres par département le
lecteur avait son choix
donc là là il y avait par cette
diversité une offre aujourd'hui on le
voit notamment avec le Crédit Mutuel qui
a racheté l'est de la France en
production de PQR du
Sud jusque au au nord de cette bande de
l'Est avec des donc des des des dizaines
de titres où effectivement il y a une
question qui se pose puisque cette
concentration est là mais ça a été
énuméré par Madame main de sa dans
l'audiovisuel groupe vivind le groupe BG
et j'en passe je ne vais pas les citer
de façon précise avec une deuxième
caractéristique qui potentiellement peut
nuire à
l'indépendanceyz je suis modéré je dis
potentiellement mais on a vu aussi par
des cas concrets que c'est pas souvent
c'est pas toujours plutôt potentiel
c'est que la caractéristique de nos
grands groupes et ça c'est pas aux
grandes démocrati qui nous entourent
c'est qu'ell vivent essentiellement de
la commune
publique et que donc
elles
ont non seulement ce sont des groupes
qui ne sont pas spécialisés dans les
médias ils font autre chose du BTP de la
vente d'arme voilà mais ils vivent de la
commande publique donc on se dit mais
pourquoi il s'intéressent au médias
c'est pas leur cœur de métier et on peut
se dire que parce qu'ils vivent de la
commande publique ils veulent influencer
la la commande publique à travers la
possession des
médias voyez c'est potentiel mais je
parle de la
réalité et donc on doit faire attention
à ce que l'indépendance des journalistes
parce que on va y revenir tout à l'heure
on peut légiférer je l'ai proposé il y a
plusieurs années sur la concentration
mais en PPL je m étais risquer c'est
compliqué parce que si on commence à
parler de seuil de concentration
capitalistique
de d'auditeurs de nombre de médias qu'on
peut posséder il faut des études
d'impact pour viser juste et on a pas
ses moyens le Parlement français c'est
pas le Parlement américain il peut pas
travailler avec autant de précision tout
seul dans le cadre de PPL donc ça aurait
été un peu du travail baclé donc on a
choisi un autre angle puisque cet
univers est celui-là avec ses dangers
potentiels et bien on va travailler sur
comment les journalistes peuvent assurer
leur indépendance dans cet univers et
les propositions de loi s'attachent à
définir à travers d'événements concrets
ce qui peut les protéger il y a cette
avancée merci Madame la Ministre parce
qu'il y a eu des
blocages pendant au moins 3 ans et vous
avez débloqué la situation sur le secret
des sources donc on y reviendra
concrètement on répondra aux arguments
de Monsieur portellier autre mais c'est
un débat qui est une avancée il y a le
droit d'opposition euh on y reviendra
aussi l'article 1 est très important
peut-être qu'on aura l'occasion de
l'aborder réellement aujourd'hui puisque
nos débats ne vont pas aller
probablement au bout aujourd'hui mais
peut-être qu'au moins cet article 1 on
va l'évoquer on y reviendra plus
précisément et puis il y a ces comités
de déontologie les audits d'indépendance
il y a ce débat sur le fait que dans
l'audiovisuel le CSA peut avoir une
prérogative de veille mais attention ne
continuons pas à renforcer les pouvoirs
ou alors à faire qu'il a des
prérogatives qu'il n'avait pas avant en
amont de euh surveillance quotidienne
des rédactions au moment où ellees
produisent l'information euh je conclus
tous ces débats on va les avoir de façon
précise à travers des amendements mais
il était utile de légiférer sur
l'indépendance des médias parce que le
paysage aujourd'hui nous l'impose et
parce que nous devons veiller nous
législateurs à faire ce que nous avons
introduit dans la Constitution au Sénat
avec un amendement des
socialistes la loi doit garantir
l'indépendance le pluralisme et la
liberté des médias c'est ce que nous
faisons en répondant à ces propositions
de loi merci Monsieur
assouine dans la suite de la discussion
générale la parole est à Madame Sylvie
Robert pour le groupe socialiste et
républicain
bonjour bien madame la présidente madame
la ministre madame le rapporteur chers
collègues quelle urgence y a-t-il à
légiférer pour renforcer la liberté
l'indépendance et le pluralisme des
médias je dirais qu'il existe deux types
de menaces pressentes une interne au
système médiatique il est déjà amplement
évoqué mais l'autre externe qui lui est
intimement corrélé oui la presse et
l'audiovisuel font face à un phénomène
de concentration qui oblige à une
attention accrue ce même phénomène
d'ailleurs est à l'œuvre dans beaucoup
de secteurs économiques et on se
rappelle les débats relatifs aux lois à
la l cap création liberté architecture
et patrimoine autour de la concentration
horizontale et verticale dans la musique
par exemple et on voit que ce sont des
tendances qui se développe en vue de
réguler l'industrie des médias les deux
lois fondatrices de 1986 portant réforme
du régime juridique de la presse et
relative à la liberté de communication
ont instauré des dispositifs de
limitation des opérations de de
concentration pour autant le défi posé
par la compétition internationale
exacerbé et la globalisation des marchés
inincit on le voit les grands groupes
médiatiques à consolider leur position
en diversifiant leur portefeuille il
s'en suit que depuis plusieurs années ce
phénomène de concentration s'accentue
dangereusement et qu'il nécessite donc
en conséquence d'être régulé le risque
qui s'est avéré réel et bien sûr
d'aboutir à une confusion entre les
intérêts économiques des groupes
détendeurs des organes de presse on l'a
déjà évoqué ou des chèmes audiovisuel et
la manière de traiter et d'analyser
l'information quand cette déviance
devient manifeste elle ébranle mes chers
collègues la confiance des citoyens dans
les médias seul 39 % aujourd'hui leur
font confiance et elle pte préjudice
bien sûr à la probité journalistique
légitimement attendue sans revenir bien
sûr sur les polémiques de la décision de
ne pas diffuser tel programme ou tel
reportage il se révélait donc urgent de
prendre des dispositions en vue d'aller
plus en avant dans la séparation des
pouvoirs entre actionnaires éditeurs et
les journalistes et dans la noningérence
directe ou indirecte des premiers dans
la ligne éditoriale des seconds en somme
il est question de cloisonner ce qui
relève de la gestion économique et
financière d'un groupe par essence
privée et ce qui a trait à l'formation
du public intérêt éminemment général
impliquant indépendance et pluralisme
pour se faire cette proposition de loi
vise à conforter et à étayer des droits
et notamment en étendant le droit
d'opposition reconnu en l'état
uniquement journaliste de l'audiovisuel
public et en concentrant le droit à la
protection du secret des sources sur ces
deux points d'ailleurs notre groupe
proposera de rétablir le texte issu de
l'Assemblée nationale il s'agit bien de
sécuriser la prof la profession
journalistique car malgré leurs droits
et la liberté théorique dont ils
jouissent et qu'ils exercent dans le
respect de la ligne éditoriale les
journalistes aussi peuvent se
restreindre à l'instar d'artistes qui
parfois et malheureusement trop souvent
en ce moment s'empêche d'aller peut-être
jusqu'au bout de leur imaginaire les
journalistes ne sont pas à l'abri de
l'autocensure mal qui bien sûr fragilise
toute démocratie conscient voir victime
des pressions économiques qui pèent sur
leur groupe ils peuvent éviter on l'a vu
certains sujets ou même s'interdire de
les traiter de façon critique de cet
engrenage il en résulte donc à minima la
perte d'une grille de lecture d'un
événement ou au pire au pire une perte
sège d'information quoi qu'il en soit
l'autocensure journalistique qui peut
être causée par un manque d'indépendance
des rédactions nuit aussi au pluralisme
et il engendre une privation
d'information pour le public si bien
qu'elle s'apparente aussi à une défaite
de la démocratie par conséquent
faciliter et apporter la sérénité
précieuse à l'exercice du métier de
journaliste est une exigence
démocratique Milan Kundera dans
l'immortalité écrivait le pouvoir du
journaliste ne se fonde pas sur le droit
de poser une question mais sur celui
d'exiger une réponse ce droit d'exiger
une réponse n'est autre que le droit à
l'information du public prémisse
indispensable afin qu'une opinion tout
simplement éclairée se révèle encore
faut-il s'assurer que cette information
soit indépendante plurielle pour que
tout à chacun puisse bien sûr se forger
une opinion libre Anna Aren dans son
livre vérité et politique disait la
liberté d'opinion est une farce si
l'information sur les faits n'est pas
garantie et si ce ne sont pas les faits
eux-mêmes qui font l'objet du débat sans
les journalistes ne nous pourrions pas
nous y retrouver dans un monde en
permetel changement et au sens le plus
littéral nous ne saourons jamais où nous
sommes comme ces phrases si percutantes
mes chers collègues raisonne en ce
moment avec l'actualité et le désormais
fameux Panama papers face au récit de
façade qui peuvent s'apparenté à des
comptes imaginaires les journalistes
font ressortir ce qu'il a parfois de
plus froid les faits sans nécessairement
chercher à faire de leur narration à
roman il démontre il démontre ce qui est
approximatif inexact ou mensongé et pour
paraphraser ConA le pouvoir de
journaliste n'est pas de déclarer la
vérité il est d'éclairer le trouble il
est de déconstruire le mensonge ni
prophète ni juge il est messager d'une
simple part de vérité mais peintre d'une
réalité brute investiguer informé
expliquer tels sont à mon sens les trois
missions principales qui reviennent aux
journalistes cette pédagogie apparaît
d'autant plus fondamentale que
l'information est devenue un enjeu
essentiel car la propagation des NTIC
qui constitue d'après Rif King la 3e
révolution industrielle démultiplie à la
fois les sources mais aussi les formats
la rapidité de circulation d'information
les réseaux sociaux on le sparchef C
géographie contemporaine des médias
elles abolissent toutes frontières elles
amplifient lesécoos des événements même
parfois les plus lointains c'est ainsi
que les les individus s'emparent de
cette de ces nouvelles technologies
d'ailleurs ils les font évoluer
perpétuellement pour leur donner un sens
création de mouvements spontané de
solidarité très moderne à tout symbole
d'une société que je trouve très active
qui se meut mais il ne il n'en demeure
pas moins pardon que le traitement et
l'analyse de l'information sont
complexifiés aussi par ces technologies
de l'information et de la communication
il s'agit d'un immense défi démocratique
face à la multiplicité de ces
informations disponib face à leur
volatilité face au sentiments que nous
ressentons parfois d'être perdu au
milieu de cette actualité sans cesse
bruyante comment bien informer comment
donner à comprendre alors que le temps
de réflexion est de plus en plus
comprimé c'est précisément ce rôle de
Vigi démocratique devenu majeur que
doivent incarner les journalistes ce
rôle est délicat à remplir on le sait il
est de manière croissante devant la
désinformation qui s'évie notamment sur
Internet parfois il convient d'abord de
démêler ce qui est le vrai du faux puis
de prouver que telle ou telle
information doit être prise au sérieux
la fonction pédagogique des journalistes
donc participe d'une entreprise plus
globale d'éducation aux médias et
notamment des plus jeunes elle est de
nature à lutter contre cette
désinformation qui se répand qui
s'enracine parfois et qui porte je
trouve directement atteinte au fondement
démocratique de notre société à une
époque où ce qui est cru et parfois plus
important que ce qui est vrai comme le
déclare un artiste dans un de ses textes
tre audible et légitime dépend autant du
contenu du travail que de la confiance
que vous inspirez c'est pourquoi cette
proposition de loi vise à restaurer la
confiance des citoyens aussi dans les
médias en reforçant la leur indépendance
et leur pluralisme faire la politique de
l'autruche estimer qu'il n'y a nul
problème et nulle urgence à légiférer
c'est tout simplement aller à l'encontre
de l'intérêt démocratique et de
l'intérêt général dans une société de
défiance pour reprendre le titre de
l'ouvrage de Yan AlGaN rétablir la
confiance dans une institution
considérée comme le 4e pouvoir ne se
décrète pas c'est le labur continuen qui
se mesure à l' des articles de presse
des émissions de radio TR programme
télévisuel cette responsabilité
n'incomte pas uniquement aux
journalistes les obligations relativ à
l'indépendance et au pluralisme qui
peuvent être intégré aux conventions
signées entre les éditeurs de services
de télévision et le CSA par exemple
pourrait être développé sous l'égite de
ces comités généralisés par l'article 7
de même ces derniers pourrait contribu à
valoriser les bonnes pratiques observées
en somme l'objectif est donc bien de
réfléchir à l'environnement médiatique
dans son ensemble à la manière d'étendre
la confiance entre tous les acteurs et
dans cette perspective les autorités
publiques l'autorité administrative
indépendante en charge de garantir la
liberté de communication audiovisuelle
et le pluralisme des opinions doivent
aussi inspirer confiance cela passe par
une impartialité objective qui se voit
tant dans les modalités de désignation
de ses membres sa composition que dans
la justification de ses décisions et et
la stabilité de sa jurisprudence mes
chers collègues la réponse commune a
importé pour ins suppl une confiance
renouvelée dans les médias se résume un
seul mot indépendance indépendance des
rédactions indépendance des organes en
charge du contrôle de cette indépendance
c'est cette finalité que poursuit et
déploit cette proposition de loi et en
fin de mon propos je veux sincèrement en
remercier les auteurs comme décrit et
écrit pardon l'auteur français Michel
des Castillo la grandeur du journaliste
se mesure par son indépendance l'actu
de cette semaine lui donne entièrement
raison
merci merci chers
collègues la parole est à
Marie-Christine Blondin pour le groupe
écologiste madame la présidente madame
la ministre mes chers collègues ce n'est
pas
l'actualité qui confère à ce texte une
quelconque urgence c'est une
contradiction croissante entre
l'indépendance et l'éthique de
l'information et le modèle économique
que se donnent les médias depuis des
décennies modèles aggravés en France par
les liens des éditeurs avec la commande
publique et la
précarisation de la profession prendre
en considération le risque pour la
démocratie que représentent ces
changements et y trouver des parades et
de notre devoir et ces textes sont
bienvenus
néanmoins les propositions peuvent
manquer leur ciblebles si elles
n'installent pas les gardes-fous
rigoureux et nécessaires que les
journalistes sont en droit d'attendre
pour exercer au mieux leur mission et
les minorations de la commission aggrave
le renoncement les relir à l'ône du
travail collectif
d'investigation des journalistes sur les
Panama papers est édifiant la protection
du secret des sources est un bien
précieux qui conditionne la liberté de
l'information elle doit être renforcée
et nous regrettons les amendements
proposé par la Commission des lois en
réintroduisant la notion d'impératif
prépondérant d' d'intérêt public
celle-ci nous rétrograde à la
formulation flou et sujette à
interprétation variable de la loi de
2010 en supprimant la sanction de
suspension des aides à la presse notre
Commission se prive de la dissuasion
tant ces aides sont
indispensables permettre de les
supprimer ne fragilise pas les
entreprises les conduis simplement à
respecter la loi la présidente
rapporteur nous rappelle que je cite le
capital confiance des Français à l'égard
de leurs médias est faible mais en
refusant de faire davantage évoluer la
législation elle n'en tire pas toutes
les conséquence et risque d'aggraver ce
capital confiance des Français à l'égard
de leurs
représentants de la suppression proposée
des dispositions relatives à la
protection des lanceurs d'alertes
pourtant voter unanimement par
l'Assemblée et qui s'articulait
pleinement avec la protection du secret
des sources des journalistes le moindre
que l'on puisse dire et que cela irait à
rebours de ire et de l'actualité récente
je vous proposerai de réintroduire cet
article essentiel pour que ces
sentinelles sacheent qu'elles peuvent
alerter quand il y a fraude
transgression de la loi ou tout autre
atteinte à l'intérêt général et je
remercie le gouvernement d'avoir
anticipé en complétant le dispositif les
écologistes sont en revanche sceptique
sur la mise en place des chartes
déontologiques maison ainsi cha
qu'entreprise ou société disposerait de
son propre texte on offrirait donc la
possibilité à certains titres d'être
plus souple en matière de déontologie
que d'autres et aux journalistes qui
contribuent d'être plus ou moins
regardant sur les conditions d'exercice
de leur métier alors qu'il existe de
solides textes de référence depuis
l'article 34 de la Constitution jusqu'à
la charte de munique la géographie
variable dans un contexte de précarité
de la profession serait la porte ouverte
au dumping éthique et à l'éclatement
d'une ligne de conduite commune qui
honore la profession un autre regret
concerne la régulation de la
concentration aujourd'hui en France C
individus milliardair dispose de 95 % de
la production journalistique leur métier
d'origine importe peu à un certain
niveau on accroche un groupe de presse à
sa boutonnière comme certains croient
que la réussite à 50 ans s'affiche par
une Relx poignet des exemples récents
ont montré que la frontière entre
information et intérêts des actionnaires
envers leurs annonceurs et mince il y a
des propriétaires de montre d'une
certaine marque qui s'indigne seul des
règles strictes peuvent éloigner le
risque de dépendance des rédaction de
comportements zlés ou
d'autocensure coup de regret peu de
satisfaction nous avions la possibilité
de mettre en place des
disposition ambitieuse pour garantir la
qualité de
l'information certains ont pensé ce
matin qu'il était urgent d'attendre pour
ne fâcher personne alors que la
démocratie vacille que le peuple n'a
plus confiance gardons nous en France de
ne brand dire qu'un sabre de bois qui
fera rire les éditeurs de presse ou
plutôt ceux qui à un moment donné de la
courbe de leur bénéfices se sont servis
de la presse comme une marchandise comme
une autre en l'état actuel le groupe
écologiste réserve son vote à
l'évolution des avancées du
texte merci chers collègues Madame
Mireille jour intervient maintenant pour
le groupe
RDSE ça va bien
merci madame le Président Madame la
Ministre madame le
rapporteur en ce moment même en Turquie
se tient le procès de kundar et herdem
Gou journaliste au sein du journal
progressiste et laïque
gouuriet ces deux journalistes
d'investigation risque aujourd'hui la
prison à perpétuité pour quelle raison
celle d'avoir publié une enquête sur la
livraison d'armes par les service de
renseignement turc à des rebelles
islamistes en Syrie au début de l'année
2014 plus que jamais cette affaire qui
fait grand bruit en Turquie et qui est
devenue l'un des symboles de la
répression de la liberté de la press
par le régime de rép Tayip Erdogan doit
nous rappeler l'importance de médias
libres et indépendants c'est l'objet de
la proposition de loi examinée en séance
aujourd'hui que de renforcer la garantie
des principes constitutionnels qui
fondent une liberté et une indépendance
des médias
effective car il faut bien le dire la
confiance du public dans ses moyens
d'information s'érode depuis plusieurs
années les raisons de cette défiance
sont protéiforme ainsi que l'explique
l'Observatoire de la déontologie de
l'information les journalistes moins
soucieux d'une certaine éthique sont
considérés comme trop proches du pouvoir
ou des puissances d'argent le phénomène
est loin d'être nouveau rappelons-nous
Albert Camu défenseur acharné d'une
morale professionnelle pour tous les
journalistes et militant pour je cite
couper les liens incestueux entre notre
profession et les puissances
d'argent de ce point de vue l'année 2015
est venue éclairer d'une lumière
nouvelle le vœux que formait l'auteur de
l'Homme révolté en
1939 puisque jamais la concentration des
médias entre les mains de quelques
industriels dont les activités on peut
àoir avec l'information et la
communication n'avait été aussi visible
et importante de libération aux
Parisiens aujourd'hui en France en
passant par l'OPS L'Express ou BFM TV
RMC les exemples ont été égrainés des
titres de journaux regroupés entre les
mains d'une poignée d'homme d'affaires
l'un de ces exemples a peut-être été
plus symbolique que d'autres tant il a
parl à notre imaginaire collectif
lorsque la reprise en main de la ligne
éditoriale de Canal Plus par Vincent
Boloré s'est accompagné de la censure de
documentairire de missission l'émission
spéciale investigation un sujet et des
questions qui ont animé les auditions de
notre
commission une démocratie ne peut que
sortir renforcé lorsqu'une loi propose
de consolider l'indépendance et le
pluralisme de ces médias car si ce
combat est avant tout celui des
rédactions et des journalistes il peut
aussi avoir besoin de l'engagement de la
représentation nationale cette loi peut
ainsi permettre de faire évoluer la
législation eu égard à certaines
pratiques devenues Cadu et favoriser
l'émergence d'autres en rapport avec
avec une certaine
actualité je pense notamment à la
jurisprudence relative au délis de
recell de violation du secret de
l'instruction dès lors que l'intérêt
général est en jeu ce délit est tombé en
désuétude à mesure que les tribunaux
prononçaient régulièrement la relaxe des
journalistes je pense également aux
dispositions visant à étendre le statut
des lanceurs d'alertes en matière
d'environnement et de santé publique où
l'importance de leur révélation n'est
plus à démontrer il est d'ailleurs
regrettable que sur ces deux point la
commission des lois comme celle de la
culture est décidé de faire marche
arrière voilà un bien mauvais signal
envoyé d'une part au journaliste
d'investigation et de l'autre au lanceur
d'alertes alors que l'actualité de ce
début de semaine et les révélations qui
ont suivi la publication des Panama
papers par le monde confirme justement à
quel point nous avons avons besoin d'eux
et par conséquent de protéger leurs
statut ou leurs
enquêtes je regrette également les
reculs de notre commission sur l'article
1er il paraissait tout à fait légitime
de généraliser à tous les journalistes
le droit d'opposition protection dont
bénéficiaient jusqu'alors les seuls
journalistes de l'audiovisuel public
notre commission a toutefois jugé bon de
supprimer l'intime conviction
professionnelle qui venait établir dans
la pratique ce droit d'opposition
or celle-ci loin d'être une humeur du
moment devait être formée dans le
respect d'une charte déontologique dont
chaque entreprise de presse devra se
doter par ailleurs c'est une notion qui
existe de longues dates pour les
journalistes de l'audiovisuel public et
dont la transposition dans la loi du 5
mars 2009 relative à la communication
audiovisuelle n'avait rencontré aucune
opposition concernant cette charte
diontologique je forme également le vœux
qu'elle permette l'inscription d'un code
de bonne conduite sur l'emploi des
journalistes et les conditions de leur
rémunération à un moment où les
conditions de travail ne cessent de se
dégrader et la part de pigiste augmenté
c'est d'ailleurs pourquoi avec certains
de mes collègues nous proposerons une
rédaction collégiale de cette charte de
déontologie enfin je proposerai
également de rétablir le dispositif de
retrait des aides publ en cas de
manquement aux obligations de
transparence de l'actionnariat ou de
violation des obligations de droit
d'opposition des journalistes le
principe me paraît suffisamment
important pour être maintenu et je ne
suis pas convaincu par l'argument selon
lequel ce dispositif de sanction serait
plus lourd pour les entreprises les plus
fragiles il le sera avant tout pour
celles qui ne respectent pas certains
devoirs qui semblent pourtant essentiels
mes chers collègues le groupe RDSE se
prononcera diversement sur ce sujet je
terminerai pour ma part par cette phrase
d'Albert Camu qui n'a pas fini de nous
faire réfléchir un journal libre se
mesure autant à ce qu'il dit qu'à ce
qu'il ne dit pas je vous
remercie merci chers collègues Monsieur
Pierre Laurand a maintenant la parole
pour le groupe communiste républicain et
citoyens
bonsoir
madame la ministre madame la
Présidente la présidente de la
commission et rapporteur mes chers
collègues la liberté l'indépendance et
le pluralisme de la presse qui oserait
prétendre qu'il ne s'agit pas là
aujourd'hui d'une question centrale pour
notre démocratie mais aussi en ce moment
d'un de ces maillons faibles notre
démocratie ne se porte pas bien et les
questions de la libre information de son
indépendance à l'égard des puissances d'
argent de son pluralisme réel et non
seulement de la pluralité des canaux
d'information sont au cœur de cette
crise
démocratique donner à toutes les
intelligences libres les moyens de
comprendre et de juger elles-mêmes les
événements du monde ce principe ce droit
fondamental énoncé par jeanjores dans
l'éditorial avec lequel il fondait
l'humanité est-il aujourd'hui assuré à
tous nos concitoyens loin sans faut nous
attendions donc sur ce sujet essentiel
une loi
importante le quinquena aura au
contraire été marqué par des mouvements
de contrôle et de concentration redoublé
dans tous les grands moyens
d'information par une précarisation
croissante d'une grande part des des
journalistes et par une instabilité
économique croissante dans un secteur à
la recherche d'un nouveau modèle
d'équilibre la proposition de loi que
nous examinons aujourd'hui en quelque
sorte une proposition de loi de
rattrapage devant ce manquement à
l'initiative législative attendue à le
mérite d'avancer donc enfin sur ces
terrains essentiels mais ces limites
sont aussi avérées elles laissent de
question de côté deux questions majeures
je l'ai dit la précarisation croissante
du métier tous les syndicats de
journalistes ont tenu à insister auprès
de nous sur cette question et les
dangers que cette précarisation fait
peser sur la qualité le libre exercice
professionnel du métier et deuxième
question majeure laisser à l'écart de ce
projet l'étouffement du pluralisme par
la concentration financière et
multimédia qui ne cesse de se renforcer
auditionné par la commission du Sénat le
président du CSA l'a pourtant reconnu je
le cite les lois antioncentration sont
dépassés nous proposons donc sur ce
point des amendements
essentiels mais au-delà il faudrait
d'urgence entreprendre un chantier
législatif d'ampleur on nous opposera je
le sais l'un perfection de nos
amendements mais qui peut le plus peut
le moins il constituerait un premier pas
dans la bonne direction et une
incitation à poursuivre on nous objecte
aussi qu'encadrer la main mise de
Messieurs Arnaud Boloré bouig dassassau
draahi berger laardire Niel pigas Pinot
et autres crédits mutuels
risquerait d'ouvrir la porte au capital
étranger anglo-saxon sur la maîtrise de
nos moyens
d'information permettez-nous de penser
que la protection du CAC 40 ne nous
assurera pas la meilleure des
garanties à ce titre je voudrais citer
Hubert beuvemie qui savait faire la
différence entre ce qu'il appelait une
industrie de presse et une presse
d'industrie c'est la seconde on dirait
aujourd'hui une presse d'argent vers
laquelle nous avançons à grand pas une
presse où disait
beuvemie il suffit que l'information
n'aille pas porter quelques préjudice à
des intérêts très matériels et très
précis ou à l'occasion qu'elle les
servent efficacement les exemples sont
malheureusement nombreux et il suffit de
regarder brièvement des exemples dans la
dernière période de merci patron des
guignoles de l'info ou d'un reportage à
charge sur le Crédit Mutuel sur Canal
Plus ou à l'inverse des préventions de
Monsieur taverneau de M6 sur le fait
qu'on ne doit pas supporter qu'on dise
du mal de ses clients à l'antenne pour
vérifier que ces problèmes sont bien là
car dans le même temps chacun le sait
des titres majeurs du
pluralisme comme l'humanité politice
médiap part mène un combat acharné et
quotidien pour assurer leur survie et en
restant
indépendant la proposition de loi
s'attaque principalement à offrir de
nouvelles garanties d'indépendance aux
journalistes et aux équipes
rédactionnelles nous soutenons plusieurs
de ces avancées celles très importantes
concernant la protection des sources et
nous souhaitons que le texte soit
renforcé en en ce domaine renforcé
également pour protéger les lanceurs
d'alertes nous nous saluons
l'instauration d'un droit de retrait des
journalistes quand un contenu lui est
imposé à l'opposé des principes
déontologiques et de ses convictions
professionnelles encore faut-il que ce
droit ne soit pas bafoué dans les faits
par la pression exercée sur chaque
journaliste par des conditions de plus
en plus précaires nous proposons
également d'aller au bout de l'intention
de transparence en exigeant la publicité
totale des mouvements d'actionnaires
dans la propriété des médias sans aucun
seuil concernant la déotologie nous
appuyons certaines avancées du texte
mais nous voulons les renforcer
clairement les garantir par la référence
aux chartes qui unissent la très grande
majorité de la profession au risque
sinon de voir des chartes maison au
rabetis fleurir dans les rédactions au
gré des rapports de force inégaux entre
actionnaires et journalistes nous
veillerons donc à introduire une
référence claire à la charte des droits
et devoirs de munique et à la charte
d'éthique professionnel adossé à la
convention collective pour les mêmes
raisons plusieurs de nos amendements
proposeront de renforcer et de garantir
le poids et les droits des équipes
rédactionnelles nous préférons ce chemin
à celui choisi par par le texte à propos
du CSA nous mettons en effet en doute
l'article qui concerne le rôle du CSA
qui partait semble-t-il d'une bonne
intention mais qui risque d'aboutir à un
effet inverse non pas la garantie de
l'indépendance mais le contrôle des
rédactions et des médias ce à quoi
d'ailleurs le CSA dit lui-même qu'il
n'est pas candidat mes chers collègues
vous l'aurez compris notre souhait est
de travailler à enrichir les garanties
apporté par ce texte qui nous paraissent
encore dans plusieurs domaines clés trop
homéopathiques
notre vote ici au Sénat sera également
dépendant du sort réservé aux intentions
affichées par la loi par la majorité
sénatoriale des fois dans les
discussions nous avons l'impression que
la voix des des grands actionnaires
souffle manifestement dans les nuque et
pour ce qui nous concerne il est clair
que nous ne voterions pas un texte vidé
de ces quelques avancées pour ne plus
avoir qu'un texte d'affichage vidé de
son sens nous resterons donc actifs et
vigilant dans la discussion pour rendre
possible le vote de disposition plus
nécessaire que jamais pour la liberté
l'indépendance et le pluralisme les
médias en l'état donc nous réservons
notre
vote merci chers collègues la parole est
à Monsieur Jean-Pierre Leleu pour le
groupe les
républicains bonsoir merci madame la
présidente madame la ministre madame la
rapporteur mes chers collègues en
paraphrasant
un de mes maîtres à chanté Jacques Brell
je dirais euh que la quête vers
l'indépendance cette inaccessible étoile
est une quête non seulement légitime
mais tout à fait louable et nous la
partageons tous et même si cela reste un
impossible rêve nous devons tenter
ensemble de l'atteindre toutefois on
peut s'interroger sur la précipitation
qui entoure l'examen de ces deux textes
qui nous sont présentés aujourd'hui et
regretter que la procédure accélérée
soit devenue ces derniers temps un moyen
habituel de légiférer à l'Assemblée
nationale le rapporteur Patrick Bloche a
justifié l'urgence de ce texte par le
souci de protéger les journalistes des
risques de censure qu'engendreraiit une
concentration grandissante des médias et
aussi à la suite de la déprogrammation à
la demande de la direction d'une
émission d'investigation sur les
antennes de Canal plus d'où le surnom
qui est venu petit à petit cette
proposition de loi de loi
antiboloré cette affaire avait
d'ailleurs fait grand bruit à l'automne
dernier on se souvient que le CSA était
intervenu que les missission avait été
reprise par France Télévision d'ailleurs
ce qui démontre quelque part que une
forme de régulation s'impose quand il y
a une transgression à cette indépendance
et qu'elle se fait elle peut se faire
quasiment naturellement personnellement
je décelle dans ce texte et cela a été
confirmé dans les débats qui m'ont
parfois mis un peu mal à l'aise un
esprit de défiance et de suspicion à
l'égard des rédactions de presse des
directeurs de journaux et de chaînes et
d'ailleurs nos interlocuteurs lors des
auditions de la commission l'ont perçu
de cette façon sont ils sont en en
revanche dans l'attente d'autres mesures
qui les aideraient à faire face à la
crise économique que traverse le secteur
depuis le développement du numérique et
qui elle en revanche justifierait
l'urgence à contrario le texte qui nous
parvient de l'Assemblée nationale
proposer de nombreuses nouvelles
contraintes pour les entreprises tel que
l'obligation de consultation annuelle du
Comité d'entreprise sur le respect du
droits d'opposition des journalistes sur
l'adaptation des convention conclu par
le CSA avec les éditeurs de servicees et
je passe un certain nombre de
contraintes qui figuraient dans ces
textes le texte a donc été sensiblement
modifié par la Commission à l'initiative
de notre rapporteur Catherine main de
Sai dont je tiens à saluer la rigueur la
qualité du travail et sa qualité
d'écoute nous avons maintenu l'extension
du droit d'opposition aux journalistes
de presse écrite tout en veillant à la
constitutionnalité de cette disposition
en supprimant la notion trop subjective
d'intime conviction professionnelle de
l'article 1er et à mon avis que je
partage d'ailleurs avec madame le
rapporteur il faudra maintenir cette
suppression ici en séence nous avons
évité un risque juridique des
complications pour le juge mais aussi
une représentation vexatoire des liens
de travail dans les sociétés de presse
l'article faisait clairement des
journalistes un contrepouvoir éditorial
pouvant désavouer leur hiérarchie alors
même qu'il disposent déjà d'un statut
protecteur et que la responsabilité
civile et pénale du directeur de la
publication est engagée il est
certainement plus utile pour garantir
cette liberté de conscience de
généraliser les chartes déontologiques
au sein des sociétés comme cela a été
prévu à l'Assemblée nationale après
l'intervention de notre groupe de même
la version initiale du texte permettait
une ingérence excessive et injustifié du
CSA et des comités d'éthique dans les
rédactions faisant du CSA une sorte
d'arbitrre voire de censeur des
relations entre les journalistes et
leurs employeurs notre commission a donc
pris une sage décision en refusant
d'étendre exagérément les pouvoirs du
CSA tout en lui reconnaissant une
mission de veille en matière de
pluralisme d'honnêteté et d'indépendance
de l'information et des programmes la
même sagesse a motivé l'examen des
articles portant sur les obligations
d'information des société en matière de
transparence du capital nous avons
choisi de relever le pourcentage
déclenchant les obligations à un niveau
plus adapté à la conjoncture actuelle de
même la création d'une nouvelle sanction
pour les manquements constatés mettant
en cause le soutien financier apporté
aux entreprises les plus fragiles nous a
semblé disproportionné et ne figure donc
plus dans la version adopté en
commission enfin je signalerai les
modifications de l'article inter sur la
protection des sources des journalistes
il y a en effet un équilibre à préserver
entre la liberté d'information que nous
appelons tous de nos vœux et les
intérêts majeur de notre société en
l'occurrence le secret de l'instruction
à côté de ces modifications nous avons
maintenu les dispositions en faveur de
la publication des annonces légales
ainsi que certaines avancées concernant
l'incitation fiscale à investir dans les
entreprises de presse votées en 2015
mesure qui on peu à voir avec
l'indépendance et la transparence des
médias et qui présente un intérêt pour
les entreprises je rappellerai qu'il
faut urgemment répondre au défis majeurs
que rencontre la presse et le secteur
audiovisuel en but à la baisse des
ventes au numéro à l'érosion et au
vieillissement des publics à la suite
des recettes publicitaires et aux
difficultés d'adaptation numérique ces
défis sont multiples le principal étant
d'assurer la survie de nos entreprises
face au développement des géons
internationaux ainsi la déccentration
des médias en Europe n'est-elle pas
forcément à mon sens un signe de menace
pour l'indépendance des journalistes
mais bien en contraire une nécessité
économique de nombreux rapports se sont
succédés pour modifier et apporter des
mesures devant les difficultés
rencontrées par les médias et
l'audiovisuel on souhaiterait que ce
chantier de réforme soit engagé et il y
en a il y a d'importantes mesures à
prendre en conclusion mes chers
collègues notre groupe apportera son
vote à ce texte dans la mesure où il
conserve la valeur ajoutée que la
Commission a adopté dans sa version
finale je vous remercie merci chers
collègues Monsieur Philippe
boncarer a la parole pour le groupe udi
UC Philippe
oui madame madame la présidente madame
la ministre madame le rapporteur mes
chers collègues renfor la liberté
l'indépendance et le pluralisme des
médias quel beau titre pour une
proposition de loi comment expliquer
qu'une telle proposition puisse faire
l'objet d'une opposition très large des
éditeurs de presse et les syndicats de
journalistes nous sommes convaincus de
l'importance des enjeux et des valeurs
d'indépendance comme de pluralisme des
médias dans la France de l'esprit des
Lumières l'indépendance de la presse est
solidement ancrée dans nos consciences
j'admet donc volontiers que l'on n'est
jamais assez exigeant jamais assez
vigilant à cet égard même si je ne
perçois pas de remise en cause sont
mises en avant nous venons de l'entendre
quelques incidents récents ou tel ou tel
reportage n'aurait pas pu être diffusé
le fait que ces éléments a donnés est
lieu à de forts débats dans la société
française montre que les principes
d'indépendance et de pluralisme des
médias sont bien vivants et spontanément
perçus comme légitimes aussi est-il
probablement excessif de nous proposer
ce texte en procédure accélérée
initiative pour partie des ordonnées
rajoutant des contraintte peu en phase
avec l'évolution des médias le risque
principal est économique c'était votre
propos il y a quelques secondes monsieur
lu euh au regard de la faiblesse de la
surface financière ou des résultats de
beaucoup d'entre eux l'économie des
médias me semble plus en danger en 2016
que leur
indépendance la dissociation entre
liberté formelle et liberté réelle s'il
m'est possible de faire un clin d'œil à
Monsieur Laurent n'est pas à
sous-estimer dans ce domaine la liberté
ne sera réelle que lorsque les
l'équilibre économique des médias
français sera de nouveau
assuré l'interrogation économique ce
double une remise en cause technologique
avec l'émergence du numérique l'arrivée
de nouveaux concurrents issus de cette
sphère acteurs internationaux le plus
souvent et devenant des médias de plein
exercice ce qui a été un des propos
madame le rapporteur qui vous a servi de
guide l'entreprise de presse
audiovisuelle ou écrite est une entre
prise qui n'a besoin ni d'instabilité ni
de complexité la faiblesse structurelle
de la proposition de loi vient du fait
qu'elle s'éloigne de cette notion
d'entreprise voire qu'elle commet des
contesens à l'exemple du rôle qui aurait
pu être confié si on était resté sur les
termes initiaux au comité d'entreprise
de la même manière vouloir faire du CSA
un juge un arbitre sur ce même terrain
déontologique alors qu'il est lui-même
acteur à travers sa compétence de
désignation ne semble pas une réflexion
aboutie dans le calendrier très bref
offert par la procédure accélérée il
était illusoir pour la commission de
l'éducation de la culture et de la
communication de travailler sur
l'ensemble du cadre économique
d'exercice des médias il serait de même
inapproprié ou Atif de vouloir modifier
les équilibres de la loi
la Commission a essayé de faire simple
efficace et d'anticiper madame le
rapporteur sur des conciliations
possibles entre journalistes éditeurs de
presse d'une part entre assemblée et
Sénat d'autre part il est permis
d'observer que la proposition de loi ne
traite pas de la définition du
journaliste
professionnel définition curieusement
toujours double avec celle des articles
l7501 113
l750011 pardon
l71115 du code du travail et celle
introduite par la loi du 4 janvier 2010
à l'article 2 de la loi du 29 juillet
1880 j'approuve les amendements
présentés par madame le rapporteur et
retenu par la commission un pas avant
important est proposé vers les
journalistes avec les chartes de
déontologie tout en laissant ouvertes
leurs conditions d'adoption afin de
donner plus de souplesse en donner en
tout cas de la souplesse aux entreprises
de presse et de ne pas dissoudre la
responsabilité du directeur de
publication c'est l'objet de l'article 1
qui à la fois généralise le droit de
tout journaliste à refuser tout pression
ou à ne pas divulguer ses sources et qui
étant la charte
déontologique à tous les médias avec une
date d'adoption réaliste j'approuve
également la clarification de l'article
1 bis au regard des comités d'entreprise
dont la vocation a bien stabilisé nous
aurons des débats sur la question des
lanceurs d'alertes euh où le choix été
de renvoyer un texte adéquat généraliste
pour éviter de tronçonner ce sujet par
ailleurs tout à fait partagé sur les
différentes bandes d'entre assemblée
mais eu au risque de sérieuses
contradictions le CSR retrouverait son
rôle de régulateur et les comités de
déontologie se verrait proposer une
définition plus adaptée notamment quant
aux conditions de ceses avec l'article 7
sur la question des protections des de
la protection des sources que vous avez
développé monsieur le rapporteur pour
avis l'idée de la commission des lois
semble pour l'essentiel de préserver ce
secret des sources autant qu'il est
possible sans modifier les équilibres
trouvés au fur et à mesure du temps par
la Cour européenne des droits de l'homme
une rédaction plus brève des
dispositions a été vu par certains qui
s'en sont émus comme en retour en
arrière là où le souci est plutôt de
pertinence juridique au regard d'une
jurisprudence bien assise soit du point
de vue du droit à l'information et de
l'indépendance des journalistes soit de
la protection de la vie privée ou de la
présomption d'innocence j'ajouterai que
l'article 1 TER pose bien le principe de
la protection des sources des
journalistes précise qu' a droit à cette
protection du secret des sources et
définit ce qui est une atteinte à
celui-ci en fixant les exceptions au
principe de manière limitative
autorisez-moi à conclure en indiquant
que notre commission a très fermement
insisté sur l'importance du maintien de
l'article 11 terre dans la version issue
de l'Assemblée nationale tant le
pluralisme de la presse hebnomadaire qui
assure un maillage essentiel dans les
départements serait atteint si l'accès
aux an lég ne leur étit pas réouvert
notamment sur les ventes dites
commerciale le sujet n'est d'ailleurs
pas limité à la presse hebdomadaire et
la presse quotidienne qu'elle soit
régionale ou nationale est également
attentive en vous remerciant mes chers
collègues de votre
attention merci chers
collègues la parole est à monie davou
groupee publain
oui pour parler maintenant plus
précisément du débat tel qu'il est au
nom de mon groupe tel qui s'est produit
après avoir présenter l'objet de ma loi
comme
auteur je veux dire que qu'il faudrait
pas qu'il y ait de confusion dans les
débats j'ai écouté attentivement madame
le
rapporteur elle a absolument par un
exposé assez précis justifié le fait
qu'on légifère là-dessus et elle a pas
jugé inutile de légiférer là-dessus
elle n'a pas considéré que finalement
comme le dit Monsieur Leleu la
régulation se fait de façon naturelle ce
sont ses propres mots donc je vois que
le débat est nécessaire et je sais
entendre la
différence de jugement par rapport à ces
lois entre madame le rapporteur et et
euh ce que nous ont dit un certain
nombre de patrons de presse et de
médias qui sont relayés de façon
quasi parfaite par Monsieur Leleu il n'y
a pas cette régulation de façon
naturelle et on n jamais considéré quand
il s'agissait du droit de et de
l'indépendance de la presse et des
médias qui on pouvait s'en remettre à
une quelconque euh régulation naturelle
on pose des droits on pose des règles on
pose des principes qui permettent
justement que la régulation ne soit pas
naturellement sauvage et quand il s'agit
là pas de l'audiovisuel publ mais de
groupe privés les rapports de force on
les connaît c'est ce qui possède qui
décide et donc quand il s'agit de
l'information il faut une protection je
voulais dire que il y a ces débats avec
madame le
rapporteur sur les précisions à apporter
par rapport à plusieurs sujet où
j'entends qu'il y ait débat même si on
n' pas les mêmes
formulations parce qu'il faut
préciser que ce soit
sur le rôle du CSA que ce soit sur les
comités d'indépendance éthique ou
déontologie par qui ils sont nommés de
qui ils sont composés quel est le champ
de leur activité quel est le regard du
CSA sur ces
comités le débat aussi sur les
ches je soutiendrai ici le fait que les
chartes ne peuvent pas être des chartes
maison déconnectés de principes généraux
de la
profession et qu'il faudrait pas qu'il y
ait de confusion là-dessus donc là aussi
je crois que ce qu'a dit Pierre Laurent
faut compte mais je n'ai pas
trouvé par la référence qui me semble
pas juridiquement très stable à des
texte
infralégislatif la bonne accroche pour
fixer les principes généraux mais toutes
ces débats sont complètement légitimes
et y compris parce que on légifère de
façon un peu trop rapide je ne suis pas
sûr toujours de défendre la position qui
est la meilleure et d'ailleurs c'est
pour cela queun de nos amendements
renvoie et une clause pas de revoyure
mais à un moment donné où il faudra que
le Parlement regarde après avoir fait ça
comment ça fonctionne est-ce que on a
visé juste est-ce qu'il faut compléter
parce que là-dessus personne ne peut
dire j'ai complètement raison mais
l'effort est fait pour mettre ces gardes
de fous il y a ces débats et y a le
débat que pose monsieur lu qui
finalement dit que on ne fait que venir
embêter des entreprises qui sont déjà
dans la difficulté au lieu de venir en
aidere sur leur difficulté franchement
il y a pas une entreprise de médiia ou
de presse dans ce pays qui peut dire
qu'elle est maltraitée par les pouvoirs
publics y compris en terme d'aide
financière au vu même de leur capital et
de leurs moyens propres hein suivez mon
regard mais franchement on devrait
plutôt dire merci à l'état de l'aide
qu'il apporte y compris dans la
distribution la presse et l'implication
qu'à l'état pour permettre ce pluralisme
aujourd'hui est à saluer et je veux moi
maintenant finir par un élément que j'ai
introduit par amendement on y reviendra
qui est que même quand on et là il y
avait consensus les revendes
spéculatives de
fréquence madame Maur de sa dans la loi
avait proposé une taxation sur les
plusvalues à 20 % pour dissuader on
était unanime
moi j'avais proposé il y a longtemps 5
c'était pas unanime mais maintenant 20
c'est unanime je suis
pour ensuite le
CSA a réagi je je je finis a réagi à
cette vente spéculative de numéro 23
confermement à ce que voulez madame main
de
sa aujourd'hui le Conseil d'État cassé
la décision je proposerai un amendement
pour donner les moyens au CSA sa mission
sans être
entravé en faisant que les attributions
de fréquence vivent une période
probatoire où on puisse vérifier au bout
de 2 ans et demi si les engagements pris
sont tenus j'expliquerai pourquoi dans
l'amendement mais je pense qu'il faut
aussi savoir légiférer en répondant aux
situations concrètes qui se pose et là
c'est un vrai camouflé pour ce qu'on a
pensé unanimement ici que les reventes
de fréquences spéculativ ne sont pas
bonnes pour la
démocratie madame ma rich pour le groupe
les républicains à la
parole madame la présidente madame la
ministre madame la Présidente de
commission mes chers collègues nous
sommes réunis aujourd'hui pour examiner
conjointement une proposition de loi
émanante de l'Assemblée nationale
Visante à renforcer l'indépendance et le
pluralisme des médias et une proposition
de loi relative à l'indépendance des
rédaction à l'initiative de nos
collègues sénateurs du groupe socialiste
et
républicain faudrait-il voir là à
travers ce tir croisé de nos collègues
de la majorité gouvernementale une
réponse à un réel danger qui qui
menacerait la liberté l'indépendance et
le pluralisme des médias en France il
est vrai que l'émergence de nouveaux
groupes de presse et les prises de
participation dans les médias doivent
nous conduire à une grande vigilance
pour préserver la liberté de
l'information et la liberté d'expression
les fondements de toute
démocratie pour ma part comme de
nombreux collègues j'imagine je n'ai pas
constaté de raréfaction de l'information
bien au contraire
nous avons en France la chance d'accéder
à une multitude
d'informations grâce à une pluralité des
support tels que la radio la télévision
la presse écrite ou encore internet s'il
est vrai que l'accès à Internet ne
garantit pas qu'il s'agit bien d'une
information c'est-à-dire vérifi par des
professionnel qui ont d'une part
identifié la source et d'autre part
recouper les FA
c'est aussi un véritable moyen de faire
circuler
l'information il convient donc de
garantir qu'un véritable travail de
journaliste a été effectué en amont qui
soit indépendant et dont la ligne
éditorial ne soit pas dicté par un
quelconque intérêt qu'il soit personnel
ou professionnel comme le souci par
exemple de ne pas déplaire à certains
annonceurs réunis pour des débattre de
ce texte je me demande si l'indépendance
éditoriale de l'audiovisuel français
serait menacé au point de vouloir
accorder au CSA plus de pouvoir et lui
conférer un rôle supplémentaire de
veille sur les bonnes
pratiques je ne sais pas vous mais moi
après la diffusion hier soir du magazine
cash
investigation consacré au panam's papers
je ne perçois pas de réelle connivance
entre le monde des affaires et celui des
médias la régulation exercée par le CSA
semble plutôt bien fonctionner et je
m'étonne de la volonté de nos collègues
à vouloir légiférer ou tout au moins
vouloir légiférer dans la
précipitation en effet nos concitoyens
ont à l'égard des médias comme à l'égard
des politiques d'ailleurs une grande
méfiance la question de l'indépendance
et de l'honnêteté de l'information
mérite d'être posée mais sûrement pas
dans le cadre d'une procédure accélérée
elle mérite un large débat public qui
tienne compte de tous les aspects autour
de cette question au-delà du seul
respect de l'indépendance éditoriale du
pluralisme des opinions ou du contrôle
déontologique je me félicite d'ailleurs
de l'important travail réalisé en
mission par nos collègues et en
particulier par notre collègue Catherine
maourin de
sali comme un certain nombre de sénateur
j'ai été saisie par des entreprises de
presse locales qui publient des annonces
légales je suis pour ma part favorable
au maintien de l'obligation de ces
publicités dans la presse papier car ces
supports sont encore trèslus et attendus
dans nos territoires ruraux et de
nombreux emplois sont concernés je vous
remercie merci merci chers collègues la
parole est à Madame Nicole Duranton pour
le groupe les
républicains donc je vais leur
dire bonjour
rebonjour madame la présidente madame la
ministre madame la présidente de la
commission culture mes chers collègues
permettez-moi de féliciter en premier
lieu le travail effectué et la rigueur
de ma collègue Catherine main de sali au
nom de la commission de la culture de
l'éducation et de la
communication nous aurions pu facilement
rejeter ce texte qui je le rappelle est
une loi de circonstan et démagogique le
texte a été amendé afin notamment de
supprimer les principales contraintes
imposées aux sociétés de presse ou
audiovisuelle je salue également le
travail de mon collègue HUG Portelli sur
la protection des sources des
journalistes il a fait adopté plusieurs
amendements visant à assurer le respect
des enquêtes et de l'instruction et plus
largement de l'intérêt public la liberté
d'information l'indépendance vis-à-vis
du pouvoir politique et le pluralisme
sont intimement liés à la démocratie et
évidemment indispensable à la vitalité
de nos débats mais force est de
constater que la proposition de loi
telle qu'elle avait été rédigée poser
davantage de questions qu'ell ne
résolvit les problèmes dénoncés de plus
nous savons tous que les textes de
circonstances et la précipitation font
rarement de bonnes loi preuve en est la
méthode de vouloir confier au Conseil
supérieur de l'audiovisuel une nouvelle
mission à savoir de garantir je cite
l'honnêteté l'indépendance et le
pluralisme de l'information et des
programmes méthode douteuse puisque nous
pouvons tout de même émettre des
réserves sur l'indépendance du CSA en
raison notamment des modalités des de
nomination de son président par le
président de la République sans aucune
exigence de compétence de plus le CSA
éprouve déjà des difficultés à
s'acquiter de ses missions traditionnel
à savoir veiller au respect de
l'expression pluraliste des courants de
pensées et d'opinion la commission de la
culture a en en effet restreint les
pouvoirs exorbitants conférés par
l'article 2 au CSA elle a supprimé le
pouvoir du CSA d'adapter les conventions
qu'il conclut avec les éditeurs de
services TV ou radio pour assurer le
respect des principes du pluralisme
d'honnêteté et d'indépendance de
l'information des programmes en effet le
23 mars dernier Monsieur schramek
président du CSA nous avait clairement
indiqué que le CSA n'avait jamais
demandé de modification législativ la
liberté l'indépendance et le pluralisme
des médias pour reprendre l'intitulé de
ce cette proposition de loi serait-il
menacé en France est-il urgent de
légiférer de surcrois en procédure
accélérée sans avoir le temps ni la
concertation ni de l'E ni de l'étude
d'impact il est vrai que notre pays a
mis énormément de temps à prendre
conscience des des bouleversements à
savoir le développement d'une presse
gratuite la révolution du numérique
l'application des réseaux sociaux tout
cela a changé les usages de nos
concitoyens et surtout à remis en cause
le modèle économique des médias
traditionnels je doute que cette
proposition de loi soit à la hauteur des
enjeux qui intéressent les médias
aujourd'hui même si certains dispositifs
me par utile est-ce que ce texte
permettra de garantir l'indépendance et
la pluralisme des et le pluralisme des
médias aujourd'hui l'enjeu et surtout
dans la survie des entreprises de presse
et audiovisuelle face aux géants
d'Internet Google ou encore Facebook
permettez-moi de rappeler également le
contexte dans lequel nous avons dû
examiner cette proposition de loi en
procédure accélérée après un doublement
des articles lors du passage à
l'Assemblée nationale puis un examen au
Sénat 4 semaines après le vote à
l'Assemblée ces conditions ne permettent
pas un travail de fond sérieux au regard
des enjeux que j'ai indiqué précédemment
c'est pourquoi je félicite notre
présidente rapporteur qui avec ses
amendements a véritablement bien défini
un socle des principes applicable aux
groupes audiovisuels et aux entreprises
de presse ces amendements préservent la
liberté éditoriale l'indépendance des
journalist vis-à-vis du CSA et le rôle
de régulateur que ce dernier doit avoir
comme à chaque fois la majorité
sénatoriale travaille dans un esprit
constructif et l'examen de cette
proposition de loi en est un exemple et
je tenais à l'indiquer je vous
remercie merci chers collègues la
discussion générale est close nous
passons à la discussion du texte de la
commission mais madame la ministre
souhaite s'exprimer je vous en prie
madame la
ministre merci madame la Présidente je
voudrais revenir sur certains des points
qui ont pu être évoqué lors de cette
discussion générale peut-être le le
premier qui qui me semble légèrement
fallacieux qui serait d'opposer le débat
sur la viabilité économique de la presse
et celui sur son
indépendance je crois que l'un nourrit
l'autre en restaurant la confiance dans
les médias à travers la proposition de
loi qui vous est soumise vous participez
aussi au renforcement de leur viabilité
économique de la viabilité économique de
ces titres de presse en en restaurant la
confiance que le public peut avoir à
leur égard et je crois que les chiffres
qui ont été cités par plusieurs
intervenants et dont dont madame le
rapporteur montre qu'il est nécessaire
de de restaurer cette cette
confiance s'agissant néanmoins de
l'enjeu du partage de la valeur et des
du modèle économique de la presse et de
l'audiovisuel vous avez soulevé un vrai
débat un débat qui est complémentaire
encore une fois et qui ne doit pas être
opposé un vrai débat auquel le
gouvernement participe pleinement
notamment à Bruxelles dans son rapport
avec la Commission européenne puisque ce
que le phénomène auquel on assiste
depuis une quinzaine d'années avec le
développement des plateforme numérique
et vous avez plusieurs d'entre vous ont
souligné le rôle du numérique
aujourd'hui dans la distribution de
l'information quel est-elle quel est ce
mouvement ce mouvement c'est
une une une une monétisation de
l'information qui se fait par les géants
du numérique au détriment de ceux qui
produisent l'information on a
l'impression que l'information est
partout qu'elle est gratuite en réalité
ceux qui la produisent en tirent moins
de Bénéfic et on voit bien qu'il y a
effectivement une fragilisation
économique de la presse dans son
ensemble derrière une illusion de
profusion de l'information qui a
également été souligné notamment par par
Sylvie Robert donc en renforçant par
ailleurs les capacités d' investigation
de la presse d'approfondissement des
sujets et bien on renforce le réel
travail d'information au détriment de
cette prolifération illusoire et de
cette fragilisation économique à
laquelle nous
assistons s'agissant du secret des sours
nous aurons l'occasion d'y revenir dans
le dans le débat monsieur Portelli a
évoqué l'égalité de tous les citoyens
devant la loi pour s'étonner que les
journalistes a droit à des droits
spécifiques liés à l'exercice de leur
métier pourtant c'est un mécanisme que
nous connaissons bien le droit au secret
médical le droit des avocats au secret
dans leur rapport avec leurs clients
protège protège la démocratie c'est pour
ça qu'il y a des droits spécifiques à la
protection du secret des sources qui
sont au service de l'intérêt général
donc il me semble que cette cet argument
ne ne ne doit pas être utilisé
s'agissant de la conciliation du secret
des sources et des exence de la sécurité
nationale qui a également été évoqué je
voudrais dire que la proposition du
gouvernement et qui a été largement
reprise par l'Assemblée nationale vise
justement à concilier les deux
c'est-à-dire les impératifs de sécurité
publique et la nécessité de protéger les
sources desour les sources des
journalistes vous connaissez je vous les
rappelle les insuffisances de la loi du
4 janvier 2010 à laquelle vous souhaitez
revenir vous avez évoqué le recel de la
violation du secret de l'instruction par
exemple qui a à mon sens n'est pas assez
n'est pas assez bien traité par la loi
de 2010 il faut bien préciser que le le
secret des sources est protégé
uniquement dans le cas où le se recèle
poursuit un but d'intérêt général je
doute que l'exemple particulièrement
scabreux que vousz vous avez
cité répondent à cette exigence
d'intérêt général et donc les
journalistes ne sont pas hors la loi et
hors sol mais quand ils défendent
l'intérêt général ils ont droit à une
protection particulière euh je voudrais
souligner encore sur ce sujet du secret
des sources la notion d'impératif
prépondérant d'intérêt public que vous
avez cité c'est une notion assez assez
floue qui est certes utilisée par la la
Cour européenne des droits de l'homme
mais le Conseil d'État a également été
consulté sur le texte que nous avions
déjà élaboré en 2013 et vous leuravez
rappelé qui était resté en suspend
depuis et il a tout à fait valider le
fait que dans cette nouvelle proposition
que nous soumettons ces cas soit
précisément listé pour être mieux
encadré et que l'on sache ce que
recouvre les l'impératif prépondérant
d'intérêt public donc ces cas ont été
listés dans le texte du Gouvernement euh
dans des des des des choix que je peux
rappeler le choix d'inclure dans ces
infractions les délits prévus par le
Titre 1 les atteintes aux intérêts
fondamentaux de laantion titre 2 le
terrorisme du livre 4 du Code pénal et
c'est donc strictement conforme à la
jurisprudence de la Cour européenne des
droits de l'homme et recom recation du
Conseil d'État datant de juin
2013 voilà pour le pour le pour le
secret des sources je voudrais ajouter
aussi un point sur les lanceurs
d'alertes qui a été évoqué par Madame
jou je crois nous vous proposerons de
rétablir ce statut particulier des
lanceurs d'alerte lorsqu'il confie des
des des secrets aux journalistes ou des
des faits qui mérite d'être porté à la
connaissance du public et je dois dire
que cela s'inscrit dans un mouvement
d'ensemble de protection des lanceurs
d'alertes puisqu'en matière financière
le projet de loi 10 sapin 2 va également
vous proposer euh de de protéger dans en
matière financière les lanceurs
d'alertes et c'est un mouvement qui me
semble parfaitement utile à nos
démocraties et on l'a vu s'appliquer
dans un certain nombre de
pays et je m'arrêterai là je vous
remercie merci madame la ministre alors
madame la ministre mes chers collègues
je vous rappelle que la présente
proposition de loi a été inscrite par la
Conférence des Présidents dans le cadre
de l'ordre du jour réservé au groupes
socialiste et et républicain pardon pour
une durée de 4h c'est-à-dire jusqu'à
18h45 compte tenu des rappels au
règlement et de la brève suspension de
séance que nous avons fait nous nous
arrêterons donc à
18h45
nous passons donc à la discussion du
texte et la parole est à Madame
Catherine Morin de
sailli beaucoup madame la la présidente
en introduction de l'article 1er avec
lequelle s'ouvr nos débats je voulais
apporter quelques précisions utiles à
notre réflexion je souhaiterit tout
d'abord rappeler les principes qui ont
présidé à nos travaux et conduit notre
commission a y apporté plusieurs
modifications d'importance lorsque la
semaine dernière elle a établi le texte
sur lequel nous nous prononçons
aujourd'hui le premier de ces principes
et mes chers collègues l'exigence de
clarté et d'intelligibilité de la loi
dans ce cadre bien sûr si notre
commission partage la volonté de
l'auteur de la proposition de loi de
voir les journalistes bénéficier des
garanties nécessaires au libre exercice
de leur profession elle est interrogé
sur la pertinence d'une partie du
dispositif proposé
elle a donc retenu le principe du droit
d'opposition des journalistes madame
Jouve contrairement à peut-être ce que
vous avez compris de
l'élaboration de cet article premer au
sein de notre
commission mais elle s'est prononcé
contre l'introduction dans la loi
fondatrice du 29 juillet 1881 relative
donc à la presse de la notion d'intime
conviction professionnelle dont la
subjectivité alors même qu'elle fonde un
droit nouveau pose vraiment question sa
constitutionalité même est douteuse car
l'absence de définition de cette notion
rend manifeste l'incompétence négative
du législateur à son endroit et partant
l'établi en contrariété avec l'article
34 de la Constitution le Conseil
constitutionnel en effet en effet se
montre traditionnellement attentif à ce
que le législateur épuise sa compétence
pour fixer les conditions d'exercice
d'une liberté en particulier lorsqu'elle
entre dans le champ de la liberté
d'expression or à la différence mes
chers collègues de la clause de
confiance et la clause de cession la
clause de conscience et la clause de
cession dont les conditions
d'application sont parfaitement définies
par le code du travail l'intime
conviction professionnelle du
journaliste sapparente plutôt un droit
moral par nature difficile à encadrer le
second principe que nous avons retenu
pour président nos travaux a été celui
de la recherche de l'efficacité des
dispositions votées et en l'espèce de
leur cohérence avec la réalité du
fonctionnement des entreprises de presse
et audiovisuel ainsi la généralisation
des chartes déontologiques à l'ensemble
des entreprises de presseend enfin
représente une avancée
significative madame le rapporteur vous
dire que nous sommes tous rentrés dans
les 2 minutes et demi maintenant donc
faites attention parce que tout le monde
veut qu'on fasse l'article prier mais
bon voilà bien je vous en prie merci
Madame la la Présidente je je je me
dépêche de terminer donc ces chartes
déontologiquesaclamé d'ailleurs de
longue date par le Syndicat national des
des des journalistes et c'est vrai que
si de grands textes nationaux je vais
pas revenir dessus hein vous les
connaissez tous sont
progressivement émergé
elles sont loin d'être systématiques
donc à l'échelle de de l'entreprise
voilà mais je soulignerz que l'échec de
la généralisation de ces chartes comme
de l'élaboration d'un texte unique qui a
été envisagé par les étatsgénéraux de la
presse en 2009 plaide par réalisme pour
des chartes d'entreprise ou ou de groupe
et là je réponds par anticipation aux
collègues qui souhaiteraient une charte
unique voilà selon le même principe
d'efficacité donc j'ai proposé à notre
commission de laisser les modalités de
l'élaboration de la charte s'adapter à
la réalité de l'entreprise merci de
m'avoir écouté merci
pierre-catherine Jean-Pierre ser a
maintenant la parole pour 2 minutes et
demi madame la la
présidente
madame la ministre mes chers collègues
en 2 minutes et demi je
remercierai mes collègues monsieur
Assouline madame Robert et les autres
d'avoir inscrit dans le temps du groupe
socialiste ce texte je lis dans cet
article 1 madame la Présidente tout
journaliste a le droit de refuser toute
pression de refuser de divulguer ses
sources et lorsqu'il signe on ne peut
pas lui imposer de signer quelque chose
avec quoi il serait en désaccord il y a
dans cet article
1 des principes fondamentaux qui sont
ensuite illustrés dans le texte lorsque
l'on
définit qui est protégé par le secret
des
sources c'est très
important toute personne qui exerce la
profession de journaliste qui exerce des
fonctions de
direction qui contribuent à la rédaction
au sein des entreprises de presse c'est
très important et de même il est
essentiel que l'on écrive noir sur blanc
qu'il ne peut être porter atteinte au
secret des sources seulement si cette
atteinte est justifiée soit par la
prévention et la répression d'un crime
soit par la prévention d'un délit qui
est par ailleurs défini il y a là madame
la présidente madame la ministre mes
chers collègues des fondements de la
démocratie et moi je regrette d'avoir
assisté depuis plusieurs années dans
cette enceinte du Sénat à des débats sur
la questions qui n'ont pas été
conclusives et qui n'ont pas affirmé
cela alors puisqu'il me reste peu de
temps vous l'avez bien compris madame la
Présidente je diraiis seulement merci
d'avoir inscrit cela mais le temps va
nous manquer et il est temps plus que
temps il est grand temps d'adopter enfin
un texte sur le sujet c'est pourquoi
madame la ministre je me réjouis de ce
que j'ai entendu dire mais peut-être
allez allez-vous le redire à savoir que
le gouvernement prendrait les
dispositions de telle manière que les
textes qui sont venus devant le Sénat
comme celui-ci ou devant l'Assemblée
puissent aller à leur terme car c'est un
engagement du du président de la
République et il serait vraiment
incompréhensible que cette protection du
secret des sources des journalistes ne
fut pas inscrite le plus vite possible
désormais dans notre législation merci
pour votre
adurgence je vous en prie
alors nous allons passer à l'article 1er
avec deux amendements qui font l'objet
d'une discussion commune c'est Madame
jou qui le présente le 34
rectifié merci madame la
Présidente
euh pour répondre à madame la présidente
de la commission culture je pense en
effet
que cet amendement sur l'intime
conviction est important et je crois
avoir compris le sens de l'article 1er
cet amendement donc vise à rétablir la
notion d'intime conviction
professionnelle que le journaliste peut
opposer à sa direction pour refuser
toute pression de signer un article une
émission ou une contribution dont la
forme ou le contenu aurait été modifié à
son insu ou contre sa volonté j'ai
entendu en commission les craintes de
contentieux que pourrait faire peser
cette mesure mais elle existe déjà pour
les journalistes de l'audiovisuel public
depuis près de 30 ans et n'a donné lieu
à aucun contentieux à outre la majorité
précédente a conféré en 2009 une valeure
législative à cette notion pour tous les
journalistes de l'audiovisuel public
pourquoi une mesure juste pour les
journalistes de l'audiovisuel public ne
le serait-elle pas pour tous les autres
par ailleurs le débat sur la légitimité
de cette notion qui a eu lieu à
l'Assemblée nationale a débouché sur le
fait d'assoir cette intime conviction
professionnelle sur des fondements
déontologiques issus de la charte de
l'entreprise donc des principes clairs
et précis il me paraît que c'est dans
cette notion d'intime conviction
professionnelle que réside la
responsabilité du journaliste d'exercer
sa profession et de l'avir
respecté je vous remercie alors le 37
monsieur assouine
oui euh merci Madame là là où il
pourrait y avoir euh une confusion pour
ceux qui ont pas suivi les débats plus
précisément c'est que le droit
d'opposition est maintenu par Madame
Morin de
sali complètement c'est-à-dire que et
d'ailleurs ça répond à tous ceux qui
disent cette loi est inutile
imaginez-vous que Madame Maurin de sa la
rapporteur dit et maintient dans cette
loi ce qui est le plus
fondamental tout
journaliste peut a le droit de refuser
toute pression de de refuser de
divulguer ses sources et de refuser de
signer un article une émission une
partie d'émission ou une contribution
dont la forme ou le contenu aurait été
modifié à son insu ou contre sa volonté
les patrons de presse que je respecte
étaient contre ça en disant ça va nous
créer le pat à caisse madame Maurin de
sa le maintient donc elle juge utile de
le dire aujourd'hui où il y a la
discussion c'est que l'assemblée a
ajouté qu'il peut
refuser un Act contraire à son intime
conviction professionnelle et là il y a
un débat sémantique l'intime conviction
professionnelle c'est moi-même qui l'ai
introduit dans la loi dit Sarkozi sur
l'indépendance de l'audiovisuel sur
l'audiovisuel publique d'accord donc ne
parlons pas d'inconstitutionnalité
madame là nous avons une divergence
parce que si c'était inconstitutionnel
ça aurait été cassé alors que c'est dans
la loi qui venait de de de de de la
droite en l'occurrence et c'est un
amendement que j'avais proposé qui a été
intégré qui est une loi de la République
aujourd'hui mais je suis d'accord avec
ceux dont madame Aurin de sa qui veulent
enlever les mots intime conviction
professionnel parce que là il s'agit pas
de le mettre dans une loi sur
l'audiovisuel public mais dans la loi
sur la presse et que là il faut que les
mots soient très précis intimes je ne
sais pas ce que ça veut dire trop dans
une oi générale et la notion de
professionnel renvoie des rapports de
négociation professionnell qui ne sont
pas complètement liés à la déontologie
du journaliste donc moi j'ai proposé une
formulation
intermédiaire la conviction mais ça peut
pas être sa conviction religieuse ou de
secte ou je sais pas quoi moi j'ai telle
conviction donc je veux pas écrire ou je
veux pas que ça doit se raccrocher à la
charte c'est-à-dire au principe
déontologique et donc mon amendement est
un amendement qui prend en compte ce que
dit Madame Maurin de sa sans affaiblir
ce qu'a voulu l'Assemblée nationale
merci madame le rapporteur c'est à
vous bien pour les raisons que j'ai
évoqué dans mon propos liminidire
lorsque j'ai pris la parole sur
l'article j'ai expliqué je pense assez
clairement la raison pour
laquelle je ne souhaitais pas que figure
dans cet article premier cette notion
d'intime conviction professionnelle
j'aiété très CLA donc notre commission a
donné un avis favorable ce matin à
l'amendement de Jouve et à celui de
Monsieur assouine mais à titre personnel
j'y suis
défavorable favorable voilà la
commission a donné un avis favorable
favorable ce matin à ces deux
amendements à titre personnel j'y suis
profondément des voir pour les raisons
que j'ai clairement exposé j'estime que
cette notion encore une fois y compris
je le regret de le dire parce que je
sais que Monsieur Assou a fait des
efforts pour trouver une rédaction qui
puisse garder le terme de conviction
mais ce sont des des notion
juridiquement indéfinies et qui sont
porteuses de risquees de contentieux
voilà pourquoi encore une fois dans une
perspective pragmatique tout en
affirmant le droit d'opposition et
l'élargissement de ce droit vous lez
noté cette article 1er élargit le droit
d'opposition à l'ensemble des
journalistes dont la presse écrite donc
c'est très important ça se trouver
inscrit dans la loi de 1881 inscrit dans
le marbre donc je crois que on a un
certain nombre déjà de de garanties qui
sont ainsi affiché dans le texte moi tel
que je vous le propose à titre personnel
donc je redis qu'à titre personnel je
suis profondément défavorable à ces deux
amendements mais la commission y a émis
un avis
favorable favorable au Pr
prier favorable au deuxè
aussi ah ben bon ben il faut voilà qu'on
soit clair hein parce
que Monsieur Carle
oui pour que les choses soient claires
pour nos collègues qui étaient pas en
commission ce matin madame la rapporteur
a émis un avis défavorable sur
l'amendement de Madame jou simplement
pour des raisons de majorité la
commission a adopté cet amendement
madame rapporteur vient de dire qu'elle
était défavorable à titre personnel à
ces deux
amendements madame la ministre l'avis du
Gouvernement je vais essayer de merci
madame la Présidente de ne pas rajouter
de la de la confusion on est parti d'un
texte conventionnel puis d'un texte
inscrit dans la loi qui effectivement
parlait d'untime conviction
professionnelle mais c'est vrai qu'à
l'Assemblée nationale a ajouté que cette
intime conviction professionnelle
s'adossait sur des chartes qui n'étaient
pas présentes dans le texte initial donc
je peux comprendre euh la tentation du
rapporteur de ne plus faire référence à
la conviction du tout en s'appuyant
uniquement sur la charte et il me semble
que le point proposé par l'amendement de
Monsieur Assouline dont j'ai oublié le
numéro euh 37 merci de l'amendement
monsieur est est un est un bon compromis
euh entre à la fois ce que souhaitait ce
que le texte initial de 2009 la position
de l'Assemblée nationale et le fait que
des chartes aient été introduites donc
je je préférais me rallier à
l'amendement de Monsieur assouine si si
Madame jou retirer le sien très bien
alors madame Blandin veut parler pour
explication de
vote madame Jouve
oui aucun problème pour le retirer bien
sûr je voterai celui monsieur
Assouline voilà pour les débats des
sénateurs autour de cette proposition de
loi socialiste déjà adopté par
l'Assemblée nationale est débattu en
procédure accélérée portant sur la
liberté l'indépendance le pluralisme des
médias vous l'avez vu les sénateurs ont
donc dû s'interrompre puisque ce texte a
été examiné dans le cadre d'une niche
parlementaire et les débats reprendront
donc fin mai vous pouvez toujours voir
et revoir toutes les séances sur notre
site
publicsenat.fr prochain rendez-vous de
l'actualité parlementaire cet après-midi
à 15h pour Sénat 360 avec Delphine
Gérard très bonne journée sur les
chaînes parlementaires
il est 13h c'est l'heure de votre
rendez-vous